CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY THE ABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW ANY I'D
LIKE TO CALL THIS MORNING IN TO
ORDER THE BEGAN I'D LIKE TO ASK
BECAUSE SPACE A MAYOR MAYOR
FULL. PLEASE LEAD US IN THE
FLAG SALUTE. I. TO THE FLAG OF
THE UNITED. AND TO THE FOR
WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE. JUSTICE
FOR ALL. AND I'D ALSO I'D LIKE
US TO TAKE A BRIEF MOMENT OF
SILENCE I TO. ABOUT OF THIS
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES THAT
BATTLING DEVASTATING WILDFIRES
ALL ACROSS THE STATE AND TO.
GIVE THANKS IN A PRAYER FOR OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS WHO ARE
PUTTING THEIR LIVES ON LINE TO
KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES. OUR
FAMILY SAFE. THANK YOU. ANTI
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE TODAY JOINING US FOR THIS
INFORMATION ON SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT INDUSTRY REGULATION I
AM CUTTING PETRIE-NORRIS AND
THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY IS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CITY
OF COSTA MESA AND MAYOR FULLY
FOR HOSTING US TODAY IN THE
CITY UNTIL CHAMBERS AND ALSO AS
CITY MANAGER LAURIE AND FERAL
HARRISON FOR YOUR HELP. IN
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS MORNING'S
HEARING. THE SCOPE AND SCALE OF
CALIFORNIA'S AMERICA'S CRISIS
IS ABSOLUTELY STAGGERING. IN
CALIFORNIA AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE
DIED FROM OPIOIDS. ACCORDING TO
THE CDC. THIRTY PEOPLE DIE IN
THE UNITED STATES FROM YOU AIDS
EVERY SINGLE DAY THIS NOW
MAKES. OVERDOSE A TOP FIVE
CAUSE OF DEATH IN OUR COUNTRY.
IT BREAKING AND AT EVERY STEP
WE HAVE SEEN PREDATORS WHO ARE
EXPLOITING. PEOPLE FOR PROFITS
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES TO
ENGAGE IN DECEPTIVE MARKETING
PRACTICES DOCTORS WHO HAVE NO
LEAD OVER PRESCRIBE THE DRUGS
AND SCRUPULOUS REHABILITATION
CENTER OPERATORS WHO ARE
EXPLOITING MISSIONS FOR PROFITS.
RIGHT HERE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
WELL THERE ARE GOOD ACTORS THAT
ARE DOING THIS WORK FOR THOSE
SEEKING RECOVERY THERE ARE TOO
MANY HORROR STORIES A PATIENT
IS RECRUITED FROM STATE BY A
BODY BROKER OUT OF NETWORK
INSURANCE POLICIES ARE
PURCHASED FOR THE PATIENT AND
RUN OUT THOUSANDS. OF DOLLARS
OR THIRTY SIXTY NINETY DAYS AND
INSURANCE RUNS OUT THESE
PATIENTS ARE CURBED
EXACERBATING ARE HOMELESS
CRISIS YES. SOMETIMES PEOPLE
ARE ENCOURAGED TO RELAPSE IN
ORDER FOR THE CYCLE TO BEGIN
AGAIN AND THIS IS A CYCLE THAT
FAR TOO OFTEN. ENDS IN PATIENT
DATA. CYCLE AS POSSIBLE TO A
TOTAL LACK OF REGULATION AND
OVERSIGHT IN THIS SPACE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR YEARS
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS THE
STRATEGY STE TRAGEDIES HAVE
WHEN ABSOLUTELY FLAT. AND IN
THE MEANTIME PEOPLE ARE DYING
EARLIER THIS YEAR I FORMED A AT
BIPARTISAN WORKING GROUP ON
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT TO
FOCUS ON THESE ISSUES. WE'RE
GONNA STOP EXPLOITATION IN THE
RECOVERY INDUSTRY ESTABLISHED
STANDARD TREATMENT PROGRAMS AND
PROVIDERS AND TO ENSURE THAT
TAX DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT
EFFICIENT. AND EFFECTIVELY. WE
HAVE MUCH WORK TO DO IN THIS
SPACE TODAY'S HEARING WILL HELP
US SHED LIGHT ON HOW
UNSCRUPULOUS OPERATORS ARE I
MEAN PATIENTS. NUMBER TWO WE'RE
GONNA LEARN ABOUT PRACTICES ON
THE LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVEL TO HELP CLOSE REGULATION
GAPS AROUND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT. AND THREE WE'RE
GOING TO LEARN ABOUT HOW
ENFORCEMENT WORKS IN ORDER TO
SHUT DOWN BAD ACTORS IN THE
FIELD AND IDENTIFY AREAS WERE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND LOCALITY.
HAD THEIR HANDS TIED WHERE WE
AS STATE POLICYMAKERS NEED TO
DO MORE I REALLY AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO TODAY'S CONVERSATION
I'D TO LEARNING TODAY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO WORKING WITH ALL
OF YOU. IN DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING REAL SOLUTION HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. AT THE FOR WE
COLLECT OUR FIRST PANEL I'D
LIKE TO PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE OTHER MEMBERS ON THE
DÍAS TO MAKE WELCOMING REMARKS.
THE MORE I MEAN I AM A STATUS
LIMÓN AARON QUIRK SILVA
PRESENT NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
WHICH INCLUDES CITIES OF FULLER
AND WHAT A PARK WEST ANAHEIM
CYPRESS STAND NUMBER COMMA- AND
THIS ISSUE IS NOT ONLY AN ISSUE
THAT I CARE ABOUT. BUT I'VE
WORKED ON IN THE PAST I WAS
ABLE TO MEET. AT WORK DIRECTLY
WITH MAYOR A KATRINA FULLY IN
AT THAT TIME FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATT. HARPER
WHERE WE HOSTED A TOWN HALL AND
HE ONLY HUNTINGTON BEACH
REGARDING SOBRE BEING HOMES. I
AND ALTHOUGH WE WERE MOVING
LEGISLATION THAT NOT MOVE WE
ARE VERY HOPEFUL WILL CONTINUE
TO. WORK TOGETHER WITH THE LEAD
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY CHAIR KADI
PETERS NOT PRESS BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT DID COME OUT OF
THAT TOWN HALL WAS TO ADDRESS.
TO THE NEIGHBORS PARTICULARLY
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT THIS
STEMS THAT PLATE ARE BROKEN BUT
EVEN WITH A BROKEN SYSTEM THERE
WERE SOME THINGS AT. WORK
CLARIFIED THOSE BEING THAT TO
MANY TIMES WHEN THERE ARE
ISSUES THAT SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
SOBRE AND HOMES- AS WOULD BE
EXPECTED THE A PARTICIPANT CALL
THE LOCAL. DEPARTMENT REALLY
CLARIFYING THAT THE STATE DOES
HAVE COMPLIANCE OFFICERS. THAT
ARE THAT PART OF THE. WEEK PART
OF OUR LOW FORMER LEGISLATION
WAS TO TRY TO GET COM A
COMPLIANCE OFFICER BASED HERE
ACTUALLY OUT OF THE CITY OF
COSTA MESA. AND MIKE WAS
MENTIONED THAT DIDN'T MOVE ALL
THE WAY THROUGH BUT I DO KNOW
AND I HAVE BEEN TOLD
SPECIFICALLY THAT WHEN THE
NEIGHBORS HEARD THAT THERE WAS
ACTUALLY. A LIVE VOICE TO SPEAK
TO THEIR WORDS SOME OF RELIEF
IN AT LEAST HAVING THE
COMPLAINTS HURT AND DOCUMENTED
AND THERE WERE SOME CHANGES IN
OUR HOMES BEHAVIOR- BUT I WILL
CLOSE WITH KNOWING THAT I'M
GOING TO BE VERY EAGER. TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS A COMMITTEE
TO LEARN MORE BECAUSE AS WE
NOTED IN THE CHAIRS OPENING
REMARKS WE HAVE QUITE A BIT OF
WORK TO DO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NOW LET ME ARE GIVE
MY APPRECIATION TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUDDY P. JEFF. DO AYE
NORRIS TO. GET OUT TO GATHER A
AND- B. OF GLEE MEMBER OF CORK
CELL. HI IT'S CERTAINLY MY
PLEASURE TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THEM ARE. THEY HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THIS LAST YEAR
THIS GOES BACK TWENTY YEARS I
THINK NOW PROBABLY TWENTY TWO
TO FOUR YEARS THAT. MEMBERS OF
THE STATE LEGISLATURE HAVE
ATTEMPT TO. BRING MORE
OVERSIGHT AND LOCAL REGULATION
AN OPPORTUNITY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HAVE SOMETHING
TO SAY ABOUT THIS WE HAVE TO
APPLAUD COSTA MESA- PRESENT AND
PAST. THEY KINDA LED TO THE
EFFORT AFTER NEW PER CHILD
SUFFERED SOME. SERIOUS
LITIGATION ALL. I IT WOULD SAY
FINANCIAL IMPACTS WHICH KIND OF
GOLD IN THE US SPIRIT IN THE
OPPORTUNITY AND- COSTA MESA
JUMPED IN A FIRE. IN OF DEEP
ENOUGH TO HOLD OF RECENTLY THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS UNDER. THE
LEADERSHIP OF JOHN WAGNER. AN
ANSWER WE'RE START TO FOCUS ON
BEING ALSO AUTHORITY REGULATORY
AUTHORITY AND ATTENTION AND
AWARENESS WHAT HAPPENS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE WE CAN REALLY START.
JUMPING IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
INSTEAD OF AT THE STATE LEVEL I
THINK KILEY SAID IT BEST WE'RE
KINDA NIPPING AROUND THE EDGES
BECAUSE WE'VE MADE PROGRESS A
LOT OF PROGRESS AND THANK YOU
TO HER OUT SHE SET UP A-
SUBSTANCE ABUSE WORKING GROUP
JUST THIS YEAR SO WE CAN. PUT
TOGETHER A CALL LEFT SIDE OF
THE ISSUES AND CERTAINLY THE
PASSION TO. HELP OUR NEIGHBOR
WE ALL LOOK AT THIS IS PEOPLE
WHO ARE DISABLED ODD I WAS A
SOCIAL WORKER ONCE UPON A TIME
BEYOND WHEN SOMEONE BECOMES
ADDICTED LIKE. VERY VERY SAD
SPEAK FOR THEM AND CERTAINLY
THEIR FAMILY AND THEIR FANS SO
WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER TO
HELP OF BOTH OF THE VICTIMS
THEN CERTAINLY. NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT ARE COMING VICTIMIZED
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
LOCAL CONTROL ON. THAT'S WILL
BE MY TOTAL FOCUS AS WE GO
FORWARD WE'VE GOT TO BRING
THEM. I TO OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SINO SHARON SERVED ON ONE I'VE
SERVED ON NOT ONE LOOK LOOK IN
A GALLON BY THE WAY I HAD A
SOBER LIVING HOME NEAR ME. AND
THE ORIGINAL OPERATOR WAS NOT A
GOOD NEIGHBOR AND WE HAD WHAT
WAS MENTIONED SOMEONE KICKED
OUT SITTING ON THE CURB A YOUNG
LADY WHO ABOUT NINETEEN YEARS
OLD CRYING AT THE KEPT.
CONFISCATED ALL OF HERBAL
THINGS THAT JUST PUT HER OUT ON
THIS PART BECAUSE HER INSURANCE
RAN OUT AND THAT WAS AT
MIDNIGHT. AS WELL DODD FOUND
GOT FROM FOR. SO THOSE THINGS
ACTUALLY OPEN WITH BAD
OPERATORS NOW WE HAVE THAT SAME
HOME OPERATING A GOOD OPERATOR
AND I'VE NOTICED THAT. A LOT OF
THE- ACTIVITIES GOING ON- KIND
OF A WALK TOGETHER ARE
CERTAINLY. IN THAT SO LIVING
HOME THERE'S PROBABLY A LOT OF.
GROUP OF HELPFUL ONLINE WITH
YOUR- COUNSEL. THOSE ARE THE
THINGS WE NEED TO SEE BUT AND
THEN IT'S NOT DISTURBING IN
FACT I GOT KIND OF EXCITED THAT
I'M SEEING DIFFERENT PEOPLE
COMING AND GOING. SO THAT THERE
ARE PEOPLE IN IT AND PROBABLY
BENEFIT. GETTING OFF THEIR
STUFF HAVING OPPORTUNITY FOR A
FULL LIFE AND THESE ARE YOUNG
PEOPLE. SO WE'RE IN IT TOGETHER
THANK YOU AGAIN QUALITY FOR ODD
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER AND I
THINK BRINGING WHERE ELSE OUT
THIS LOCAL LEVEL THEN ON UP TO
STATE. THAT TWENTY TWENTY MIGHT
BE THE YEAR WE COULD DIFFERENCE
THAT I MENTIONED TO. A FEW HERE
THAT THIS IS BEEN TWENTY YEARS
IN THE MAKING AND I'M THE
TWENTY TWENTY MIGHT BE A GOOD
OMEN. THAT AFTER TWENTY YEARS
WE ARE GOING TO REALLY READ.
SEE OUR. IN THAT WE REALLY A
MOVE THAT NEEDLE- TO OUR REAL
BILL THE SOURCE AND I HELP ON
BOTH SIDES OF THIS ISSUE SO
THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT AND
IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE AND I'M
REALLY ANXIOUS TO HEAR OUR
PANELS. BOTH FOR YOUR SEVEN
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP IS THAT WE
MOVE FORWARD INTO THE NEXT
SESSION. I WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO CALL OUR FIRST SET OF
PANELISTS OUR FIRST PANEL IS
THE RECOVERY EXPERIENCE HOW
HAVE CLIENTS. THEIR FAMILY AND
PROVIDERS BEEN IMPACTED. WE'RE
GOING TO ACTUALLY HAVE OUR
PANELISTS JOIN US HERE SAID
THAT SIDE. THE FOLKS IN THE
AUDIENCE CAN HEAR THEM AS WELL.
I SAW LANDERS AND NANCY CLARK
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADD MINUS
HERE. UNFORTUNATELY OUR OTHER
PANELISTS WINDY MCINTYRE. SHE
LIVES IN A COMMUNITY THAT BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE I BY THE POWER
OUTAGES. I SHE GOING TO DO HER
BEST TO JOIN US. THE SESSION-
BUT WE'LL WE'LL CARRY. ON THIS
FIRST PANEL WITH OUR TWO. TWO
SPEAKERS. GOOD MORNING JOINING
US MORNING. AND NANCY DO YOU
WANNA GO AHEAD AND START US OFF.
IT WILL BE INTRODUCTION OF ME
I'D BE GREAT IN OFTEN SHARE
YOUR PERSPECTIVE. MY NAME IS
NANCY CLARK BECAME INVOLVED IN
THE RECOVERY COMMUNITY NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR- I DEVELOPED AN
ALTERNATIVE SENTENCING PROGRAM
IN THE COURTS HERE IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND- THE PURPOSE WAS TO
REDUCE RECIDIVISM. BY GETTING
HELP FOR PEOPLE WITH DRUG AND
ALCOHOL PROBLEMS MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS AND THE LIKE- THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM I HAD WAS
FINDING RESOURCES FOR THESE
PEOPLE SO IN NINETEEN NINETY
WITH THE HELP OF SOMEONE I WENT
TO COLLEGE WITH IN NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. I OPEN THE
RECOVERY CENTER AND SO WE HAVE
BEEN THERE FOR TWENTY NINE
YEARS WE ARE A NINETEEN UNIT
APARTMENT COMPLEX AND WE ARE
STATE LICENSED FOR THIRTY EIGHT
BALLOTS- WE TREAT MEN AND
WOMEN- ALTHOUGH RIGHT NOW AT
THE PRESENT TIME WE DON'T HAVE
ANY WOMEN THERE- ALWAYS
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES. AND. IT
IS A LABOR OF LOVE- MY
PHILOSOPHY IS PROBABLY A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT THAN MANY OTHER.
TREATMENT PROVIDERS BECAUSE ALL
OF MY RESIDENTS HAVE TO FOLLOW
A DRESS CODE THEY PARTICIPATE
IN COMMUNITY SERVICE OUR GOAL
IS TO HAVE THEM EMPLOYED. AND
PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY. SO I WANT TO PROUD
OF WHAT I DO FOR A LIVING. AND
I'M HERE TO HELP IN ANYWAY I
CAN TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN. YEAH
SAM. GOOD DAY EVERYONE MY NAME
IS LANDERS I AM A VERY ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE RECOVERY
COMMUNITY COUNTY. I WAS VERY
FORTUNATE TO GO TO THE FORD
CENTER MY SOBRIETY IT IS
FEBRUARY SECOND NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR GROUP STAY. YES TOMORROW I
WILL HAVE TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND
NINE MONTHS SOBER AND CLEAN. I
WAS VERY FORTUNATE TO- BUT
SPONSOR WHO WAS ALSO THE
DIRECTOR THE FOUNDER AND
DIRECTOR OF STONE'S ADOLESCENT
RECOVERY HER NAME WAS PATTY A
CHILL UP. SHE HAD THE MOST
INTEGRITY WAS MOST ETHICAL
PERSON I'VE EVER MET IN MY LIFE
SHE AND I OPENED A SOBER
LIVING. IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
FOURTEEN IN LAGUNA HILLS AT
LAGUNA HILLS LAGUNA LANDING
SOBER LIVING FOR WOMEN. ARE WE
DID NOT ACCEPT INSURANCE WE HAD
A PRICE POINT OF TWELVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH I WAS ABLE TO
STAY IN IT FOR A LITTLE UNDER
THREE YEARS- I BASICALLY LOS
MEASURE. AND THAT IS BECAUSE-
WE WERE SO STRICT ON WHO WE LET
IN. WE REQUIRED AT LEAST FIVE
MEETINGS A WEEK WE REQUIRED YOU
TO BE OUT OF THE HOUSE BY EIGHT
THIRTY IN THE MORNING. X. ARE
AND SO FORTH THE- WE WERE ONE
OF THE GOOD PLAYERS I WAS
UNABLE TO SUSTAIN IT. I AM
DELIGHTED THE SMOKING TO HEAR
SENATOR BATES INVOKE THE GOOD
PLAYERS AND REMIND TO THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING AN
OUTSTANDING JOB. I DID PUT
TOGETHER A FEW NOTES HERE.
THERE'S A LOT OF HOPE IT
DOESN'T FEEL LIKE IT BECAUSE
THIS IS OVERWHELMING. BUT WHEN
I EIGHT. I'M IN THE MEETINGS
ALL THE TIME I LEFT MY NINE
THIRTY WOMEN'S MEETING IN
MISSION VIEJO TO BE HERE. AND I
WAS IN A MEETING LAST NIGHT IN
SAN CLEMENTE SIX PM AND
YESTERDAY MORNING UP IN A
MEETING SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO. AT
TEN AM SO I SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
I SEE PEOPLE RELAPSING AND- I
KNOW THAT. THOSE OF US IN THE
RECOVERY COMMUNITY. OF BITTER
INVOLVED IN IF HOWEVER ARE
INVOLVED IN TREATMENT CENTERS
SO RELIVING WE USED TO SAY
ABOUT THREE OUT OF FOUR OR THE
BAD PLAYERS. NOW WE SAY ABOUT
NINE OUT OF TEN. BECAUSE OF THE
MONEY. AND IT IS ABOUT MONEY
BECAUSE OF THE GREED. SO ONE OF
THE THINGS I WANT TO SAY YOUR
TODAY IS. LET'S CORRECT BUT NOT
OVER CORRECT. AND I DON'T HAVE
ALL THE ANSWERS BUT THE COUPLE
THINGS. SPECIFICALLY THAT I
WANT TO MENTION ONE IS. I DON'T
SEE ANY WAY AROUND THE
FOLLOWING WHEN I HAD MY SOBER
LIVING WE HAVE A TOTAL AMOUNT
OF VISITATIONS FROM ANYONE
POLICE OR ANYBODY ELSE ZERO.
ZERO IN ABOUT LITTLE UNDER
THREE YEARS. THE ONLY TIME WE
WERE CHECKED OUT AS I WAS
LIVING OF THAT SOBRE SOBER
LIVING AT WORK WHICH IS A GREAT
GROUP AND A GREAT ORGANIZATION
THAT IS TRYING TO DO GOOD WORK.
WE WERE NEVER THEY DID INSPECT
THE- AND THEY WERE VERY
THOROUGH AND GREAT JOB. WE
NEVER HAD ANY CONTACT FROM THE
POLICE WE NEVER HAD ANY
OVERSIGHT. I KNOW THAT WE HAD
CREATED A FAMILY THIS MOST
PEOPLE WE EVER HAD AT ONE TIME
WAS FOR. WE CREATED A FAMILY
AND A SENSE OF COMMUNITY IN THE
HALL THAT'S HOW PEOPLE STAY.
SOBER CLEAN IS TO HAVE A
FEELING OF BELONGING A FEELING
OF COMMUNITY. WITHIN THE HOME.
I DON'T SEE ANY WAY AROUND THE
FOLLOWING. A LOT OF MONEY. IS
GOING TO HAVE TO BE EXPLICATED
TO PERFORM SPECIAL TEAMS. THAT
ARE VERY WELL TRAINED VERY
SPECIALIZED AND HOPEFULLY
RECRUIT- INCLUDE AT LEAST
SOMEONE FROM THE RECOVERY
COMMUNITY BECAUSE. AS A FORMER
ALCOHOLIC AND ADDICT I CAN TELL
YOU SOMETHING THAT. SOME OF YOU
KNOWN SOME OF YOU DON'T. WHEN
WE'RE DRINKING IN USING. WE ARE
THE SNAKE IS MOST MANIPULATIVE
CLONING IF YOU DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE KNOCKING ON THE DOOR
UNANNOUNCED. THE BAD PLAYERS
ARE GOING TO FIND A WAY AROUND
IT YOU HAVE TO PUT SPECIAL
TEAMS TOGETHER WELL TRAINED.
RISE VISITS AT ALL TREATMENT
SOBER LIVINGS ALL TREATMENT AND
SOBER LIVINGS. AND PLEASE ON
THOSE TEAMS AT LEAST ONE PERSON
WHO IS IN A RECOVERY BECAUSE WE
KNOW IT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE.
THAT YOU GUYS STONE AND THAT
YOU TO FRUSTRATE ME AND I
FINALLY REALIZED. WITH PATIO
CHOSE HELP HOW COULD YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH HOW CAN YOU UNDERSTAND
THE UNIQUE HEALTH OF ALCOHOLISM
AND- ADDICTION IT'S SOME. IT'S
INCREDIBLE BUT ONE THING THEY
DIDN'T TELL ME AT THE BETTY
FORD CENTER TOLD ME A LOT OF
GREAT THINGS BUT THEY DIDN'T
TELL ME IF YOU STAY CLIENTS
OVER. YOU GONNA GO TO A LOT OF
FUNERALS. I CAN'T BELIEVE HOW
MANY FUNERALS I'VE BEEN TO.
I'LL LEAVE YOU GUYS WITH THIS.
I SUGGEST ALL THE TIME FOR
EVERYONE TO ATTEND MEETINGS OF
ALCOHOLICS ANONYMOUS NOT
BECAUSE YOU'RE A- AN ALCOHOLIC
OR MEETINGS OF NARCOTICS
ANONYMOUS NOT BECAUSE YOU'RE AN
ADDICT. BECAUSE THEY HAVE OPEN
MEETINGS THAT CAN OPEN YOUR
MINDS AND EXPOSE YOU YOU CAN
HEAR THE SPEAKERS AND YOU CAN
ALSO GO UP TO THE PEOPLE THAT
RULE OUT OF THE VANCE FROM THE
TREATMENT CENTERS YOU CAN WALK
UP TO THEM YOU CAN INTRODUCE
YOURSELF YOU CAN TALK TO THEM
YOU CAN EXPERIENCE ONE ON ONE.
AND I HAVE A SPECIFIC OUT THAT
I'M HOPEFUL THAT EVERYBODY IN
THE ROOM PARTICULAR PANEL WILL
DOWNLOAD THE APP IS CALLED
MEETING GUIDE. IS A WHITE CHAIR
WITH THE BACKGROUND IT IS THE
BEST OF. CAJUN THE MEETINGS IN
THAT BEFORE. OPTION UNDER TIGHT
AND YOU GOING THAT HAPPENED YOU
PUT OPEN. PLEASE ATTEND AN OPEN
MEETING PREFERABLY MORE SO THAT
YOU CAN SEE IT FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AND YOU CAN TALK TO
THE PEOPLE IN THE TREATMENT
CENTERS AND YOU CAN SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON AND ONE FINAL COMMENT
AND SPIRIT. OF A COOPERATION IN
A CULTURAL CHANGE THAT THE GOOD
PLAYERS IN THE. IN THIS IN THE
INDUSTRY- FEEL THAT THERE'S A
SORT OF A SPIRIT IT'S VERY
ADVERSARIAL. AND A CULTURE OF
THE US VERSUS THEM AND IF WE
CAN BEGIN TO CHANGE THAT AND IF
WE IF WE CAN BEGIN TO EMBRACE
AN ALTAR OF. INCLUSIVITY
INSTEAD OF EXCLUSIVITY. AND
WORK WITH THE GOOD PLAYERS YEAH
I'M A NINE TO TEN I DON'T KNOW
MAYBE IT'S NINETEEN OUT OF
TWENTY NOW IT'S SO. HORRIBLE
AND THE RATE OF RELAPSE YOU
CANNOT BELIEVE IT WHEN I GOT
CLEAN AND SOBER NINETY FOUR
PEOPLE DIDN'T TYPICALLY RELAPSE
THANK GOD I'VE NEVER RELAPSE
THAT'S WHY I GO TO A LOT OF
MEETING. I HOPE EVERYONE WILL
ATTEND OPEN MEETINGS OF
ALCOHOLICS ANONYMOUS DOWNLOAD
THAT APP AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE. THE EFFORTS IT'S
GOING TO TRYING TO CORRECT THIS
PROBLEM IT'S NOT EASY THERE'S
NO EASY SOLUTIONS THERE'S A LOT
OF HOPE AND YOU GUYS ARE MOVING
FORWARD AND I'M VERY IMPRESSED
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME. TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE SO
YOU. YOU MENTIONED THAT AT ONE
POINT IT FELT LIKE IT WAS.
THREE FOUR THE PLAYERS IN THIS
SPACE WERE BAPTIZED AND NOW
IT'S LIKE NINE TO TEN MAYBE
NINETEEN OUT OF TWENTY. FROM
BOTH OF YOUR PERSPECTIVES WHAT
DO YOU THINK IS DRIVING. THAT
SHIFT IN DRIVING SO MANY
UNSCRUPULOUS ACTORS AND SO MANY
YOU KNOW PREDATORY PLAYERS. TO
GET IN THIS SPACE NET PROFIT.
IT'S THE MONEY OKAY MY THOUGHT
IS THAT YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN EVERY WHO GO INTO THIS FIELD
AND ACTUALLY TO HELP PEOPLE BUT-
THEY USED TO BE ADDICTED TO
DRUGS ALCOHOL THEY BECOME
ADDICTED TO MONEY. AND THEY CUT
CORNERS AND THEY DO WHATEVER
THEY HAVE TO DO BUT ANOTHER
ANOTHER PLAYER IN ALL OF THIS
IS THE INSURANCE COMPANIES.
THEY NEED TO BE THEY NEED TO
CORRECT THE WAY THAT THEY DO
BUSINESS BECAUSE INHERENT IN
INSURANCE BILLING. IS ONE
FALSEHOOD AFTER ANOTHER AND IT
BECOMES THIS GAME OF A RECOVERY
CENTER TRYING TO CONVINCE THE
INSURANCE COME THAT THERE'S
MEDICAL NECESSITY FOR
TREATMENT. THEY THEY GO BACK
AND FORTH LIKE A PING PONG BALL.
IT SHOULD NOT BE OUT. ON THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO NOT PAY
OUT ANY MONEY. AND THEN THE
RECOVERY CENTERS ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO GET THE
LAST NICKEL. WHETHER THAT IS
HONEST TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED
OR NOT- OVERSIGHT IS DEFINITELY
THE ACTION THAT NEEDS TO BE
TAKEN. AND I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH YOU AND PATTY WAS ONE OF
MY- BIG HEROES- SURPRISED IT'S-
ABSOLUTELY NO IF YOU'RE RUNNING
YOUR FACILITY CORRECTLY YOU
SHOULD NEVER BE WORRIED.
OVERSIGHT OR NOT. FOR PEOPLE
DROPPING BY- FOR TWELVE YEARS I
HAD A SOBER LIVING IN COSTA
MESA WE HOUSE SEVENTY TWO
PEOPLE AND I BET NONE OF YOU IN
THIS ROOM KNEW THAT. BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY PROBLEMS WE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY ISSUES. IT WAS
A GOOD FACILITY IT DID HAPPEN
TO BE SURE OF CERTIFIED WHICH
MEANT THAT THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT CAME BY ON A REGULAR
BASIS AND COSTA MESA CODE
ENFORCEMENT CAME BY ON A
REGULAR BASIS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE OPERATING. A PRO LIFE.
OVERSIGHT IS THE ONLY ACTOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS ON THE AIR SIR
CERTIFIED IS THAT NOT SOMETHING
THAT. ANY A SOBER LIVING HOME
COULD IT TAINT THROUGH A
CERTAIN PROCESS. DON'T THEY NO
LONGER HAVE THAT NOW WE
CONTRACT WITH THE SHASTA MEANT
TO PROVIDE SERVICES YOU
RELEASED FROM JAIL. THAT'S WHAT
NECESSITATED THE CERTIFICATION.
IT WAS REALLY EASY IT WASN'T
DIFFICULT TO MAINTAIN- BUT GAVE
US LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY. AND
THEN ALSO- FOR SANDY SELL SELL
YEAH SORRY YOUR UP THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY YOU KNOW I
THINK ANY OF US WHO. OTHER YOU
HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER IN MY CASE
I HAVE. A BROTHER WHO. IT WHO
HAS NOT ONLY DEALT WITH
ALCOHOLIC ADDICTION BUT ALSO
DIED THIS PAST YEAR. BUT I
GUESS THAT'S ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS WOULD BE I ALSO HAD
ANOTHER SISTER THOUGH- HAD
ISSUES BUT WAS ABLE TO IN MANY
WAYS. BE ABLE TO RECOVER AND
SHE HAS TALKED THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS IT'S BEEN PROBABLY TWENTY
YEARS. YOU MENTIONED YOUR
BIRTHDAY I KNOW THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IF YOU'VE TALKED
TO SOMEBODY WHO'S WHO
RECOVERED. THEY OFTEN TELL YOU
ALMOST TO THE MINUTE YOU KNOW
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FIFTH THAT.
AND SHE ALSO WAS GONNA MANY
MEETINGS BUT WHAT MAKES THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SOMEBODY WHO
MAY GO INTO RECOVERY OR HAVE
SUPPORT IN BOTH CASES THEY DID.
AND I KNOW SOME WILLINGNESS TO
ACCEPT IN ALL OF THESE THINGS
BUT SOMEBODY WHO JUST. TAKES
ONE PATH AND THE OTHER DOESN'T
IT I MEAN IF THERE'S THEIR FATE
CAN YOU CANNOT. IT'S ONE OF THE
MOST RELEVANT SELLING QUESTIONS
THE ANSWERS THAT IS SUCH A
COMPLEX. DIFFICULT THING TO
UNDERSTAND. YOU ON THE MAIN KEY
YET I SPONSOR A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WOMEN PAT MONSTER.
I'M SO HAPPY YOU. DO YOU KNOW
HOW INCREDIBLE SHE WAS. GO TO
ELAINE WE DO TO GET DRUGS AND A
DRINK INTO USE WE'RE WILLING TO
DO IT YOU HAVE TO APPLY THIS
MENTALITY OF NEW SPONSOR
YESTERDAY ARE YOU OR ARE YOU
NOT WILLING TO GO TO ANY
LENGTHS. I INVOKE. GOT IN THIS
IF YOU INVOKE A HIGHER POWER
IT'S IN THE STEPS I YOU KNOW
IT. IS A PERSON WILLING TO USE
THE STEPS AND WILLING TO VOCAL
INVOKE A HIGHER POWER ALSO IF
YOU'RE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO GO
TO A REPUTABLE. TREATMENT SOBER
LIVING OR PLACE LIKE I WAS
BETTY FORD CENTER YOUR
FOUNDATION IS OUTSTANDING I HAD
A FOR WONDERFUL FOUNDATION FROM
DAY ONE. THAT IS ONE OF THE
MOST PAINFUL QUESTIONS IT IS
BECAUSE SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
DYING IN SO MANY KIDS GOING IN
AND OUT. OF I WILL SAY THIS AND
I BROUGHT A PAMPHLET FOR YOU A
FROM COLLEGE OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES BECAUSE- ALMOST ALL OF
US HAVE A CO OCCURRING MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDER I DO. I'M NOT
ASHAMED TO ADMIT IT I USED TO
BE. AND THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED TO AND THAT GETS VERY
COMPLICATED BECAUSE THAT CALLS
FOR OUTSIDE HELP AND IT'S A
VERY STICKY THING BUT YOU KNOW
SOME PEOPLE HAVE SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS. SOME DON'T- BUT-
WILLINGNESS TO GO TO ANY
LENGTHS SOME PEOPLE TO BE ON
THE GRASP OF. IT'S AMAZING TO
SIT MEANINGS IN TWO PEOPLE
SHARE AND TALKING TO PEOPLE GO
IN AND OUT AND TO TRY TO FIGURE
THAT OUT. YOU HAVE TO PUT IT
FIRST BEFORE EVERYTHING
INCLUDING YOUR CHILDREN YOUR
HUSBAND YOUR WIFE YOUR JOB
EVERYTHING. WHAT I HAVE SEEN IS
THAT- RECOVERY IS CONTAGIOUS
AND YOU CATCH IT MEETINGS. AND
YOU NEED TO BE IN GOOD ME AND
YOU NEED TO BE AND SAFE BEATING
JUST LIKE YOU NEED TO BE IN IN
A SAFE RECOVERY ENVIRONMENT.
THERE IS NO WAY TO DETERMINE.
WHO'S READY AND WHO'S NOT
EXCEPT BY WHAT THEIR ACTIONS
ARE- I HAVE SEEN PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LOST LOVED ONES JOBS HOMES
EVERYTHING AND THEY STILL ARE
READY- IT'S A VERY ELUSIVE.
ELUSIVE THING WHAT YOU NEED TO
KEEP TRYING YOU IT'S KIND OF
LIKE DIETING- BUT THERE ISN'T A
PERSON IN THIS ROOM WHO WENT ON
A DIET ONLY ONE TIME IN THEIR
WHOLE LIFE AND THEN WHEN IT
DIDN'T WORK SAID WELL I'M JUST
GONNA BE FAT FOREVER- YOU HAVE
TO STAND UP BRUSH YOURSELF OFF
AND HAVE TO DO IT AGAIN. RING
DIFFERENT TOOLS WITH YOU. WHAT
I HAVE SEEN CHANGE IN THE
RECOVERY BUSINESS THE LAST
FORTY FIVE YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN IT. IS A LOT MORE
COAL CO OCCURRING DISORDERS- WE
HAVE A LOT MORE PEOPLE COMING
INTO RECOVERY. WHO HAVE BEEN
USED TO SAY. CO CO OCCURRING
DISORDERS ARE YOU HAVE A LOT
MORE PEOPLE- WERE SUBJECTED TO
ABUSE MOLESTATION ALL.
DYSFUNCTIONAL FAMILY YOU. WHEN
I STARTED WORKING RECOVERY IN
THE SEVENTIES BASICALLY ALL YOU
NEEDED TO DO WAS SOBRE SOMEBODY
UP. AND THEY WENT ON AND DID
PRETTY WELL- BY THE EIGHTIES
THE END OF THE EIGHTIES IN
PARTICULAR. DRUG ADDICTS WERE
NOT HAVING DRUG ADDICTED
CHILDREN. SO YOU DIDN'T HAVE
PEOPLE COMING FROM THESE INTACT
FAMILIES YOU NOW HAVE PEOPLE
BRING ALONG A LOT OF BAGGAGE
AND WITHOUT GETTING
SIMULTANEOUS THERAPY ALONG WITH
RECOVERY. THEY THEY WERE NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO STAY SOBER.
THEN ENTERS THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION. DON'T GET ME
STARTED ON THEM BECAUSE MOST
DOCTORS KNOW VERY LITTLE ABOUT
COVERING AN ADDICTION AND IF
THEY'RE TRAINED TO TREAT THE
SYMPTOMS THEY'RE TRAINED TO
WRITE PRESCRIPTIONS THEY'RE
TRAINED TO MAKE GOAL WAY
WHATEVER IT IS YOU'RE
COMPLAINING ABOUT A MOMENT. SO
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
DON'T GIVE SAN NEXT TO AN
ALCOHOLIC WHO COMPLAINS THAT
THEY HAVE ANXIETY- IT'S FINE
BUT WHEN TO BE. AND SO THERE
ARE SO MANY FACETS TO THIS THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY DOCTORS THE
CITY. AND EVEN THE RECOVERY
INDUSTRY- RIGHT NOW IF I HAD A
POINT WALK INTO MY OFFICE WHO
NEEDED TO BE DETOX. I'D BE HARD
PRESSED WHERE TO SEND THE WE
HAD SOMEBODY THAT. THAT SO
DURING MY OFFICE WAS TRYING TO
FIND A DETOX AND FOR THE OTHER
DAY AND- RANDY BEDS. SO FOR THE
PERSON WANTS TO GET SOBER WHERE
DO THEY GO WITH THEY DON'T HAVE
INSURANCE AND IF THEY DON'T
HAVE THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. THANK YOU I'M JUST A
QUICK FOLLOW UP THAT IS
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT. ALL
OF US AT THE STATE LEVEL ARE
GRAPPLING. DALY BECAUSE NOT
JUST THAN TALKING OUT AN
ADDICTION OR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE WE TALK ABOUT MENTAL
MULTIPLE ISSUES AND THEN YOU'RE
ALSO ADDING TO THAT
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE FOR MANY
OF THEM THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS. SO
WE HAVE HAD VERY SERIOUS
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT INDIVIDUAL
CITIES THAT ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE HOMELESSNESS ISSUE
AND THAT COULD BE A TEMPORARY
SHELTER- ORANGE COUNTY
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S A FULL DAY'S
WORTH OF A COMMENTARY ON HOW
WE'RE ADDRESSING THAT BUT THEN
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY ALL OF
THOSE ISSUES. THEN WHEN YOU ADD
IN THE DIRECTION WITH POSSIBLY
A MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE IT
COMPLICATES IT EVEN MORE
BECAUSE- SOMEBODY WILL EVEN IF
TWO OF THOSE ISSUES WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY DO WELL ON
EMERGENCY SHELTER. AND
CERTAINLY INTO PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IF WE HAD
THEM WHICH WE HAVE A HUGE LACK
OF BAD WOULDN'T NECESSARILY DO
WELL THERE SO WE HAVE LOCKED UP
WHAT ARE SOME OTHER
ALTERNATIVES. TO THOSE TWO
SCENARIOS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT.
IS THERE A THIRD FOR THREE
FIFTH TYPE OF LOSING SO THAT WE
HAVEN'T LOOKED AT AT AND.
WITHOUT YES. SPENDING A LOT OF
TIME TALKING ABOUT MY BROTHER
BUT I GUESS IT'S IN A YEAR ONE
YEAR TWO WEEKS AGO THAT HE
PASSED AWAY IT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT OF COURSE JUST THE FACTS
THAT INDIVIDUAL IS YOU KNOW IT
AFFECTS THEIR FAMILY MY MOTHER.
IS EIGHTY FOUR AND HAS SUFFERED
INCREDIBLY SENSES PASSING- AS
WELL AS- ALL OF US SO. I THINK
THAT WHEN PEOPLE TO HAVE THAT
INTERACTION THEY CAN HAVE THE
EMPATHY AND SYMPATHY TO NOT
JUST DISCARD PEOPLE. AND NOT TO
JUST GIVE UP BUT THERE'S
ANOTHER PART WHERE. I MEAN I
CAN'T TELL YOU IN MY WORK HOW
MANY TIMES I'VE HAVE HEARD WHAT
JUST PUT HIM ON A BUS AND SEND
THEM OUT TO THE DESERT. OR
LET'S JUST SEND THEM THE SAN
BERNARDINO OR IN A ORANGE
COUNTY IS A GREAT PLACE BUT
THINGS ARE SO EXPENSIVE AND WE
REALLY WHY WOULDN'T WE SEND
THEM TO A AREA WHERE. THE COST
OF LIVING IS CHEAPER AND THEN
IT ALL MAKES SENSE AND THESE
ARE NOT SOLUTIONS THEIR
SIMPLISTIC. IN A VERY COMPLEX
WORK. AND IT WAS ELECTED
LEADERS IT'S OUR JOB TO NOT
MOVE INTO A PATHWAYS THAT TAKE
US DOWN A ROAD OF. A LEAN
TOWARDS A SOLUTION THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY NOT A SOLUTION IF
YOU ASK CENTER BERNIE DO YOU
KNOW WHAT THEY WOULD THINK
ABOUT THAT. I DON'T THINK THEY
WOULD THINK THAT WAS GREAT IF
U. S. DESERT CITIES BUT THERE
COULD BE SOLUTION IN. AN
INCREDIBLE. MARK BECAUSE WITH
SOME FIRST PLEASE WOULD BE THE
IDEA THAT THERE COULD BE A HOST
THE. LET'S BILL THIS TIME
WHETHER IT BE A MENTAL HEALTH
SLASH ADDICTION CENTER. AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO HOST IT COULD
PROVIDE JOBS BUT THAT HAS TO BE
A MUTUAL AGREEMENT VERSUS WAS
JUST PACK EVERYBODY UP AND GET
HIM OUT OF HERE. SO THANK YOU I
THINK THAT- SORT OF BUILDING
ON. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CLUBS ALL
THOSE FACING. I THINK THAT THE
SIMPLE FACT IS THAT THE INNER
SEVEN TREATMENT IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT SYSTEM OF CARE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA
FUNDAMENTALLY BROKEN. AND WE
ARE DEALING WITH THE FALLOUT
FROM DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE
FIFTY YEARS AGO. THAT'S THE BAD
NEWS I THINK THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT RIGHT HERE IN ORANGE
COUNTY WE ARE MAKING. SOME
REALLY INCREDIBLE STE. AT THE
WELL I'M MENTAL HEALTH AND WHAT
HAD THERE IS THE GROUND
BREAKING THAT FACILITY IN
ORANGE A COUPLE WEEKS AGO MANY
OF US MANY OF US WERE. THAT AND
THIS IS GOING TO BE A CUTTING
EDGE. YOU'RE KIND OF BEST IN
CLASS FACILITY RIGHT HERE IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND THERE IS A
VISION THAT WE WANT. AS A THREE
TABS THE BILL SIR THE NEEDS. OF
ALL ORANGE COUNTY RESIDENTS
REGARDLESS OF ABILITY TO. FOR A
HOT HANDS TO USE. MY CELL THERE
DEFINITELY SEND SOME POSITIVE
THINGS ON THE HORIZON. THERE IS
ON THERE SO MUCH MUCH MORE THAT
WE NEED TO DO. SENATOR MAKES
QUESTION FIVE. I USED TO BILL
AND THIS GOES TO SEE. OF THAT
WOULD HAVE REQUIRED BACKGROUND
CHECKS FOR PEOPLE WHO WERE OF
ASKING WHO ARE GOING TO
OPERATORS OF THE R. T. APPS.
AND THE BILL OF FELL ON HARD
TIMES BECAUSE FELT IT WOULD BE
THE MINOTAUR A TO DO A
BACKGROUND CHECK AND DISCOVER
THAT ZOMBIE LIKE YOURSELVES SAL
HAD THE PROBLEM BUT WAS
RECOVERED. HANDED THAT WOULD
SHOW UP IN A BACKGROUND CHECK
AND I SAID- BETTER THEY ON ONE
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WAS
RECOVERED TO RUN ONE OF THOSE
WOULD YOU FEEL FROM SORT OF A
FILM FOR OFFENDED IF YOU WENT
IN REPLY IN YOU THERE IS A
BACKGROUND CHECK AND CHILLED
OUT BECAUSE MY BILL ALSO
PROVIDED. THE DESCRIPTION OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES. TO PUNCH YOU BECAUSE
WHEN YOU TO BE ABLE TO SHOW
THAT YOU HAD ON THE TWELVE
STEPS THAT YOU WERE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUE THAT. MEAN TO ME
YOU BE LAYING OUT YOUR RECOVERY.
HALF IN THAT WOULD BE VERY
CONVINCING I AM NOT ABLE TO
CONVINCE SOME THE. THE POWERS
THAT BE THAT THAT WAS THE
PROVISION BILL THAT WOULD HELP
THE RESULT I INTRODUCED THE
BILL IS BECAUSE THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA NEWS GROUP IN THERE
IT WILL ON A YEAR LONG
INVESTIGATION FOUND THAT THE
OUT TO BE ONE OF THE MAJOR
PROBLEMS. CREATING BAD ACTORS
IN IN THIS BUSINESS SO WHY NOT
GO TO THE HEART OF THAT AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THE RIGHT
KIND OF PEOPLE WHO'VE
EXPERIENCED WHAT YOU DID TO BE
RUNNING THESE RECOVERY CENTERS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHAT THE
PASSED THE HOUSE AND THAT KIND
OF A LONG QUESTION WITH THE
STATEMENT BUT I'D LIKE TO HEAR
YOUR- THOUGHTS ON THAT BECAUSE-
WE CAN. RESTART SOME OF THE OF.
WE HAVE. THE THANK YOU OF OUR
IN OUR LET'S THEIR
PRESENTATIONS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT WE WILL HELP
OUR GET PEOPLE THINKING
DIFFERENTLY IN GET THINGS
PASSED BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE WE
GET STOPPED AND THINGS THAT ARE
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE AT
THAT MOMENT FROM AB IN FACT
THIS IS A GOOD THING. IT'S NOT
FROM DETERRENT. IN NOTHING
BERRA THING A DISCRIMINATORY. I
WAS SHOCKED THAT I WASN'T
CHECKED OUT I WAS SHOCKED THAT
I WASN'T SCRUTINIZED I WAS AND
NOBODY. LOOKED CARE. I ALSO
SHOT FROM A ROOFTOP THE I AM
PROUD THAT I'M CLEAN AND SOBER
AND- PATIO CHIRLA. TO BE I
WOULD HAVE DONE IT WITHOUT HER
AND BALD MEN SHE'S EXPERT ON
THIS AND THE WHOLE PURPOSE WAS
TO CREATE A KEEP A FAMILY
WITHIN THE HOME. WHAT YOUR BILL
WHAT YOU JUST SAID TO ME IS
SOLUTION AND EFFECTIVE.
EVERYBODY GOING INTO THIS WHO'S
GONNA RUN SHOULD BE CHECKED OUT
THOROUGHLY BACK EVERY KIND OF
BACKGROUND CHECK. I DON'T KNOW
THAT THERE'S ANYTHING IN MY
BACKGROUND THAT WOULD COME UP
THAT SHOWS I'M IN RECOVERY
OTHER THAN MY SHOWING UP THINGS
LIKE THIS AND SAYING IT. WE
HAVE SOMETHING CALLED THE
ELEVEN TRADITION THOSE OF YOU
IN RECOVERY NOW IT IT'S A
VIOLATION TO SAY YOU'RE A
MEMBER OF. A PARTICULAR GROUP
PATTY AND I WENT TO A OF A BIG
SYMPOSIUM ON A IT'S PERFECTLY
FINE TO SAY YOU'RE- A WOMAN IN
LONG TERM RECOVERY. WHAT I GOT
OUT OF THE BETTY FORD CENTER I
CALLED THE VERY DAY I GOT OUT
TO ASK HOW I WAS DOING AN
INTERVIEW FOR A MAGAZINE-
BECAUSE I WAS A MUSICIAN AT THE
TIME AND- I ASKED SOUNDS BETTY
FORD HANDLE. SHE SAYS I REFER
TO AS I SEEK A SOLUTION- AND
SUPPORT IN TWELVE STEP GROUPS.
SO LETTING PEOPLE KNOW YOU'RE
IN RECOVERY IS A GREAT THING
WHAT YOU TRY TO IMPLEMENT I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY ANYBODY
WHO. CARERS AND WHO WANTS TO DO
THE RIGHT THING WOULD BE
ADVERSE TO THAT THE ONLY REASON
WHY YOU'D BE ADVERSE THAT AS
YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO HIDE. THE
ONLY REASON. I WOULD THINK THAT
IF I'M IF I'M A RECOVERING
ADDICT. AND I DO I DOUBT- YOU
KNOW THE HIGHER POWERS
DIRECTING ME TO HELP MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE IN THE SAME
BOAT. I WOULD WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPLY FOR A-
LIFE AND CITY AND- **** SURE I
STORY IF I COULD BE VERY
CONVEYANCE I'M THINKING LIKE
YOU HAVE BEEN HERE ON THIS
PANEL. BOB SO SOMEHOW WE HAVE
TO GET OUT. OF STE WITH PEOPLE
COMING TO OUR COMMITTEES
INTENSIFYING WHO ARE. YOU KNOW
REFORM TO RECOVERED ADDICTS.
THE OTHER THING I TRIED TO DO
WAS. OUT FIND FUNDING FOR A- A
FACILITY IN SACRAMENTO. ARE
THEY OUT TO IS SEEN CHARMS
PROGRAM WHICH I ACTUALLY HELPS
WOMEN WHO HAVE THEIR CHILDREN
MOVE BECAUSE THEY- HAD
SUBSTANCE ABUSE SOLVE. ITS OF
LIKE A CAMPUS AN INDIAN TEACHES
THEM AND TING ON HOW TO GET
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE YOU
NAME IT. THREE OF THE WOMEN WHO
HAD BEEN CAMPED AT HAND BLOSSER
CHILDREN AT DICTION AND ALSO.
BEING INVOLVED IN THE ON THE-
THAT. CAME TO TELL US WHY DID
THE PRE SHEET IT BEING DRUG.
WHICH WAS A REQUIREMENT ARE WE
DO NOT SUPPORT. GIVE MANY TOUR
ANY SORT OF PROGRAMS THERE'S
DRUG TESTING BECAUSE IT'S
HOUSING FIRST BUT IF YOU CAN
LIKE ME HAVING TO WATCH YOU FOR
THE LAST- MANY MANY YEARS I'VE
BEEN FIVE A WHEN I GO INTO A
WAIT OUR CONTROL PROGRAM I LOVE
TO BE WEIGHED BECAUSE ON FRIDAY
WHEN I'M GOING AND I MAKE SURE
I'M NOT EATING WHAT I
SHOULDN'T. SO TO ME IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL NEED THAT
LITTLE EXTRA MOTIVATION SO IF
I'M AN ADDICT AND I KNOW I'M
GOING TO BE DRUG BUT AND I'M
GETTING MY CHILDREN BACK THERE
I BEEN SEPARATED FOR THERE WERE
THREE YOUNG WOMEN ARE BARELY
OVER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN BLOCK
GRANTS CRYING OUT THIS
COMMITTEE MEETING AND THEY
STILL DIDN'T PASS THE BILL THAT
WOULD ALLOW THIS. TO BE OUR
COMPLETED A COMPETITIVE I'LL
GRANT PROGRAM WHERE THEY WOULD
BE GIVEN MONEY TO EXPAND IT
TAKE MORE ARE MORE INDIVIDUALS
I THOUGHT YOU GUYS- THAT WE ALL
NEED TO AS HUMAN BEINGS THE
MOTIVATION NOT TO EAT THAT
DON'T. NOT TO TAKE OUT NEXT
WHATEVER RADIOS BECAUSE THERE
SOME HIGHER THAN JUST THE
SATISFYING. URGE TIME WORKING
TOWARDS. HE CAME TO BAT YOU GOT
IN THE RECOVERY CENTER AND USE
OUR WILL REALLY REALLY HELP US
AS WE REINTRODUCE LEGISLATION
THAT SOME OF THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND JUST GETTING DRUG
TESTED. IS SOMETHING HEY PLEASE
DRUG TEST ME PLEASE TELL US
THAT I TOO COULD DONATE
YESTERDAY AND SHOULD NOW. NOW I
GAINED HALF A POUND. IT IT
HELPS US. THE HUMAN NATURE I
SPEAK TO THE BACKGROUND CHECKS
YEAH THE ISSUE. OF FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS PROBATION DEPARTMENT
HAD AND. APPROVED LIST OF
FACILITY. AND IT. CRIER AND OF
THAT WAS THAT EVERYONE STAFF
HAD TO HAVE A BACKGROUND. THEY
ALSO REQUIRED A MINIMUM OF TWO
YEARS OF SOBRIETY THERE REALLY
ISN'T ANY BACKGROUND CHECK ON
YEARS OF SOBRIETY. BUT IT. IT
WOULD BE REALLY ALL THAT A
PERSON HAD STOPPED GETTING
ARRESTED IN GETTING IN TROUBLE
THE PERHAPS IT WAS BECAUSE THAT
THEY HAD THEY HAD GOTTEN SOBER
THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT
DISBANDED THAT UNIT BECAUSE OF
FUNDING. BUT WHEN THAT UNIT WAS
OPERATIONAL THE COURTS. WOULD
NOT SEND ANYONE TO A PROGRAM
THAT WAS NOT ON THEIR APPROVED
LIST THEREFORE. YOU KNOW
KNOWING ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
WORK THERE HAD PASSED A
BACKGROUND CHECK THE ONE
DRAWBACK ON A BACKGROUND CHECK
IS IT ONLY TELLS YOU AN ARREST
RECORD. AND SO YOU WOULD HAVE A
PROBLEM MAKING A VALUE JUDGMENT
WITH IS THEIR ARREST RECORDS SO
HORRIBLE THAT THEY SHOULDN'T BE
ALLOWED TO DO THIS WHEN IN MANY
CASES THAT COULD BE THE VERY.
IMPETUS FOR SOMEONE TO GET
SOBER AND THAT WOULD BE A VERY
VALUABLE THING FOR THEM TO HAVE
BUT IT CERTAINLY WOULD TELL YOU
THAT THE PERSON. ISN'T
CURRENTLY ON PROBATION OR
PAROLE AND OPERATING A FACILITY
BECAUSE NO ONE ON PROBATION OR
PAROLE SHOULD OPERATE. A SOBER
LIVING RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROGRAM. BE EMPLOYED THERE IN
MY OPINION. ONE THING ORDER
COMPLICATED TO LOOK MORE
HIDEOUS THIS IS OF. PEOPLE WHO.
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME PEOPLE
THAT REALLY DON'T LIKE THIS.
WHO RUN IT SERVER LIVINGS
TREATMENT CENTERS WHO ARE GOOD
PLAYERS THOSE OF US WHO WERE
CLEAN AND SOBER. IT IS HAPPENED
A RELAPSE CAM TO THEM TOO. AND
OF THERE HAS TO BE SOME
OVERSIGHT SOME WE. I KNOW I
KNOW PERSONALLY KNOW PEOPLE
WITH FORTY THREE YEARS SOBRE
THAT HAVE RELAPSED OF THERE ARE
I PERSONALLY KNOW OF GOOD
PLAYERS IN THE IN THIS
COMMUNITY IN THIS TOWN IN SAN
CLEMENTE IN SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO
I ALSO KNOW OWNERS THAT HAVE
RELAPSE THEMSELVES AND ARE. AS
WE SAY OUT THERE THEN THAT'S
NOT LIKE A MENTAL THAT'S
MEANING OUT THERE USING AND
DRINKING- IT'S A REALLY COMPLEX
THING BUT I REALLY THINK THAT
ONE OF THE CORE THINGS IS THE
PEOPLE THAT RUN THE GOOD
PLAYERS- NEED TO BE NOT ONLY
CHECKED INITIAL. BUT ONGOING.
NOT JUST IN THE BEGINNING. AND
THERE HAS TO BE TEAMS OF PEOPLE
THAT SHOW UP UNANNOUNCED.
EXPENSIVE PROPOSITION I CAN'T
FIGURE OUT ANYWHERE AROUND THAT.
WELL THANK YOU BOTH AGAIN DREAM
PART IS I THINK AS AS PAT PAT
SAID AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
YOU KNOW POLICY SOLUTIONS AND
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION I THINK
THAT THIS PARTNERSHIP IS GOING
TO BE INCREDIBLY POWERFUL SO ME
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WE
LOOK FOR TO WORKING. THANK YOU
AS WELL I HAVE A LOVELY PARTING
GIFT. MOVING ON TO OUR SECOND
PANEL WHICH IS. ON WHAT IS REAL
TREATMENT WILL BE HEARING FROM
A HANDFUL OF THREE EXPERTS. FOR
DIED IN FOR LOS WHO'S THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND GENERAL COUNSEL
FROM HIS HOLDEN BETTY FORD
FOUNDATION. AND DOCTOR RANDOLPH
HOMES HOMES THE CARE OF THE
PUBLIC POLICY CAN. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY ADDICTION
MEDICINE. WELCOME TO BOTH YOU
AT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. RIGHT JENNIFER WILL
GO AHEAD AND START WILL GO WITH
YOU. WELL GOOD MORNING IN-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
AS WELL- THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY TO DISCUSS SUCH
AN IMPORTANT TOPIC. POLITY
ADDICTION TREATMENT- AS THE
CHAIRWOMAN. A SEATED I AM THE
HE'S AND BETTY FORD FOUNDATION
OUR ORGANIZATION FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE NOT FAMILIAR WITH
US- IS THE LARGEST NONPROFIT
PROVIDER OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT IN THE
COUNTRY. WE STARTED IN NINETEEN
FORTY NINE AND TODAY WE'VE
EXPANDED- INTO SEVENTEEN SITES
IN NINE DIFFERENT STATES
INCLUDING THE BETTY FORD CENTER
RANCHO MIRAGE INTO OTHER
OUTPATIENT CENTERS HERE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. UP AND
THROW THE COUNTRY WE TREAT MORE
THAN TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
ANNUALLY INCLUDING THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS- BOTH AT OUR
CLINICS AND THROUGH OUR VIRTUAL
CARE SERVICES. ARE NONPROFIT
ALSO INCLUDES AN ACCREDITED
GRADUATE SCHOOL OF ADDICTION
STUDIES A PUBLISHING HOUSE
RESEARCH CENTER- AND EDUCATION
ARM OF FOR MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS IN A PROGRAM FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN WHO ARE
STRUGGLING WITH ADDICTION AND
THEIR FAMILY. IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE COUNTRY HIS THAN BETTY FORD
HAS A BILL THAT SELF TO EVERY
OPTIONAL AND MANDATORY
ACCREDITATION AND LICENSING-
THAT IS PERTINENT TO OUR WORK
OUR HIRING STANDARDS FOR
COUNSELORS. REQUIRE AT LEAST A
MINIMUM OF A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
AND- YOU KNOW STRONG PREFERENCE
TOWARDS A MASTER LEVEL
CLINICIANS. THE BETTY FORD
CENTER OUR LARGEST CENTER HERE
IN CALIFORNIA- MAINTAINS
LICENSE AND CERTIFICATION
ONLINE TO FULL TREATING
CONTINUUM. WITH LONG SUPPORTED
QUALITY BASED STANDARD. AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON AND CRACKING DOWN
ON UNETHICAL PRACTICES. BUT
REALLY MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE-
ALTHOUGH I FEEL DOES REALLY
GREAT WORK I TO ENSURE OPTICAL
QUALITY CARE FOR THOSE WHO SEEK
ADDICTION BELIEVE IT'S TIME TO
ESTABLISH QUALITY STANDARDS AND
A MANDATORY CONSISTENT
ENFORCEABLE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK. FOR ADDICTION
TREATMENT CALIFORNIA. IT'S WITH
THIS BACKGROUND THAT I'M HERE
TO IT TO TALK ABOUT THREE WAY
IS THAT K. MISSION IMPROVE
REGULATION I THE DICTION
SHIPMENT INDUSTRY. THROUGH
COMPREHENSIVE OLD OVERSIGHT OF
PROGRAMS AND FACILITIES AND
INDIVIDUAL LICENSING STANDARDS
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS. BASED ON
OUR EXPERIENCE AS A NATIONAL
SYSTEM OF CARE THAT SPANS MANY
STATES. ALSO I WANNA START SOME
HUMILITY WE LIKE ALL PROVIDERS.
I BY NO MEANS PERFECT. WE ARE
MAKING A LOT OF CHANGES TO OUR
AGING BUILDINGS AND FACILITIES
TO MAKE THEM MORE ACCESSIBLE
AUDITING A MYRIAD OF STANDARD-
THROUGHOUT OUR NATIONAL SYSTEM
OF CARE- AND TRYING TO PROVIDE
THE BEST AND HIGHEST QUALITY
SERVICES THAT WE CAN. BUT WE
FEES CHALLENGES AND WE STRIVE
TO GET BETTER EVERY DAY. WE
OFTEN PARTNER WITH OUR STATE
LICENSING ORGANIZATIONS TO DO
THAT. IN CALIFORNIA THE FIRST
STEP TO REFORM MUST BE TO
ESTABLISH AND ENFORCE PROGRAM
STANDARDS THAT ARE MANDATORY
AND QUALITY FOCUSED IN THE
OUTPATIENT SETTING A VOLUNTARY.
NATURE OF STATE CERTIFICATION
AND OF ITSELF IS PARTICULARLY
PROBLEMATIC. FROM QUALITY CARE
TO BILLING AND NUMEROUS OTHER
FORMS OF PREDATORY BEHAVIOR. IN
NO OTHER OF OUR HOME ST STE-
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT LICENSE
HERE OPTIONAL. INSTEAD STATES
MAINTAIN LICENSING BASED UPON
SPECIFIC QUALITY BASS LINES SO
FOR EXAMPLE IN ORDER AND IN
MINNESOTA OUR STATE LICENSE
AGENCIES HAVE CODIFIED
STANDARDS FOR DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF CARE. WITHIN BOTH INPATIENT
AND OUTPATIENT SETTING SO FOR
EXAMPLE AN UP WITHIN A
RESIDENTIAL LICENSE OR A
RESIDENTIAL LEVEL OF CARE
DOESN'T ADAM- AUTOMATICALLY
EQUATE TO A DETOX LICENSE
THAT'S A SEPARATE LEVEL OF
LICENSING. I'M AND- A VERY
ATION TO RESIDENTIAL LEVEL OF
KERR. SO THIS AND POOR-
HIGHLIGHTS THE IMPORTANCE OF
QUALITY. THE VOLUME OR NUMBER
OF HOURS OF SERVICES ALONE IS
NOT AN EFFECTIVE INDICATOR OF
QUALITY TREATMENT. WHAT HAPPENS
DURING THOSE HOURS IS MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT THAN HOW MANY HOURS
ARE ACTUALLY PROVIDED. IN OTHER
STATES SUCH AS MINNESOTA LEGAL
SANDERS RECENTLY MODIFIED TO
INCLUDE MORE FOCUSED HARD ON
QUALITY. YOU KNOW AN HOUR OF
YOGA DOES NOT EQUATE TO AN HOUR
OF TRAUMA THERAPY FOR OUR
PATIENTS NOTHING WRONG WITH
YOGA LOVE YOGA. IT'S NOT THE
SAME. REGARDS TO FACILITIES
BECAUSE CERTIFICATION IS
VOLUNTARY AND NOT CONSISTENT
FACILITY STANDARDS ARMED FORCES
THE CONDITION OF RUN A PROGRAM.
WITHOUT ENSURING THAT BUILDINGS
ARE SAFETY CODED EGRESS IS
AVAILABLE FOR AN EMERGENCY
MEDICATIONS ARE CAPS FOR
TRADERS AT THE RIGHT
TEMPERATURES. JUST TO NAME A
FEW PATIENT CARE IS ALMOST
CERTAIN TO BE AT HIGHER RISK OF
AND COMPROMISED AND VULNERABLE
PEOPLE PUT AT RISK. SANDERS FOR
PROGRAMS AND FACILITIES. TO
PATIENT OUTCOMES AND JUST AS
IMPORTANT ARE THE STANDARD SET
FOR PROFESSIONALS PERFORMING
THIS LIFESAVING WORK IN THOSE
PROGRAMS. WELL TRAINED AND
CREDENTIALED COLLECTIONS ARE
CRITICAL TO PROVIDING CLINICAL
CARE. CALIFORNIA UNLIKE A
NUMBER OF OTHER STATES NEW YORK
ILLINOIS MINNESOTA WORKING HAS
NO MANDATORY SAY OVERSIGHT
FUNCTION FOR THE MANY OP
PROFESSIONALS TREATING THIS
VULNERABLE POPULATION. INSTEAD
MAINTAINS A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM
THE THIRD PARTY OR XIN THE
VOLUNTARY STANDARDS ARE MORE
LIMITED THAN WHAT WE SEE IN
OTHER STATES. AND IN OTHER
PROFESSIONAL WORK IN CALIFORNIA
SUCH AS SOCIAL WORK OR L.
MATISSE. AND THEY ARE NOT
REFLECTIVE OF THE EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS NECESSARY TO
DELIVER QUALITY CARE. IN
ADDITION EDUCATION SOME OF
OTHER HOME STATES- INCLUDE
BACKGROUND STUDIES FOR THE
FOLKS THAT ARE WORKING WITHIN
OUR FACILITIES THAT WAS BROUGHT
UP WITH THE OTHER PANEL. AND
HAVING MORE ROBUST VULNERABLE
ADULT REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
FOR THOSE PROFESSIONS. SO IN
CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
MY BACKGROUND PRIOR- TO COMING
TO HIS WITHIN BETTY FORD I WAS-
IN ACUTE CARE. AND SINCE
JOINING THE FOUNDATION. I
REMAIN REALLY SHOPS AT THE LACK
OF A COMPREHENSIVE REGULATION
FOCUS ON PATIENT CARE. NOT JUST
FOR TWO YEARS BUT THOSE IN A
VAULT IN THE ENTIRE CONTINUUM
OF CARE SOBRE HOME OPERATORS
RECOVERY PROFESSIONALS IN MORE.
IN MY ESTIMATION THIS IS DUE IN
PART TO THE FACT THAT THE
SPECIALTY EDUCATION FIELD. HAS
LONG BEEN MARGINALIZED AND A
STEP REMOVED FROM MAINSTREAM
HEALTH CARE IT'S NOT INTEGRATED.
NOT TAUGHT IN MEDICAL SCHOOL
NOT EVEN RECOGNIZED AS A
SPECIALTY UNTIL RECENTLY. MY
CAPITA SEPARATED WHICH IS ONE
REASON THAT IT'S POSSIBLE TO
EXIST UNDER A LESSER REGULATORY
SCHEME. I HOPE TO- PLAY A PART
IN CHANGING THAT TODAY AND I
THINK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY AND YOUR LEADERSHIP.
WHERE CAN YOU HEAR THANK YOU
WHAT YOU SAID ALL I KNOW HOW
MUCH BUT FOR ME TO SAY. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE I'M ANY
HOMES- I'LL BE BRIEF- USUALLY
THERE'S I. SAY USUALLY HAS MORE
QUESTIONS THAN THAN WHAT I CAN
SAY BUT I'M I AM A AND SHE
MEDICINE PHYSICIAN HERE IN
SELLING FOREIGN IN THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR FOR TREATMENT PROGRAM.
LEVIN LOCATIONS. AND I'M
CHAIRMAN OF THE PUBLIC POLICY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DECIDED
ADDICTION AS WHICH IS THE STATE
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN SIDE.
MESSENGER A SAM. WE ARE THE
LARGEST POSITION GROUP THAT
REPRESENTS. DOCTORS AND OTHER
SOCIAL NOW THAT TO TREAT
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS EN EL
MY ROLE IN SEIZE MS IS A PUBLIC
POLICY CHAIR SO I DO
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY FOR THEM I
AM ALSO THE CO CHAIR OF THE
POLICY FOR A SAM THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION SO I HAVE WORK
HERE CHECK AND I WORK IN
WASHINGTON. AND I SIT ON THE
BOARD BOTH ORGANIZATIONS- SO
ARE INTERESTED IN IN IN IT
TODAY'S TOPIC IS SYNCING OF
TREATMENT PROGRAMS AS MOST OR
MAYBE YOU DON'T THAT CALIFORNIA
NOT LAPSES OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE CERTIFIED AND
YOU COULD BE CERTIFIED BY BY
ANY ONE OF A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS BUT WE- SEE SAID
MY ORGANIZATION AT ADVOCATES TO
BE LICENSED AND I THINK
INCREASING STATE OUR SITE IS A
THING. AND WE SUPPORTED THE
BILL. THAT UNFORTUNATE AGO I
DIDN'T DID GET DIDN'T. PASSED
THROUGH HIM. SUPPORT THE BILL
THAT THAT EXISTED THIS YEAR
NINE TWENTY AND IF THIS BILL
COMES UP AGAIN IF WE CAN MAKE
SOME OF THE FINANCIAL
ARRANGEMENTS THIS BILL STARTED
IN THE SENATE I THINK JERRY
WILL START THE BILL AND THEN IT
MOVED TO THE ASSEMBLY AS BILLS
DO. WE ARE ORGANIZATION
CERTAINLY WILLING TO SUPPORT
THIS AND ON AND I WOULD AND AT
LAST YEAR WE WILL CO SPONSOR
WHICH MEANS WE ARE WILLING TO
PROVIDE EXPERT WITNESS
TESTIMONY FOR THE- FOR MANY
THINGS AND I THINK. IF YOU HAVE
WILL ENSURE YOU HAVE OVERSIGHT
AND WE WOULD THINK THAT. THAT
WE ARE OUR ORGANIZATION FEELS.
THE ALL EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENTS FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS ALCOHOLISM ADDICTION
ISSUES NEED TO BE OFFERED AT
TREATMENT PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO
GET A LICENSE SO THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT EVERY SINGLE PERSON
WHO GOES THROUGH TREATMENT
NEEDS TO BE ON MEDICATION
THURMOND EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENTS WHICH YOU'RE NOT
MEDICAID USUALLY YOU THINK OF
EVENTS PASTRY. THAT INVOLVE
MEDICATIONS. THE SUBOXONE BEING
THE ONE THAT PEOPLE CARE ABOUT
THE INJECTABLE- TRAWL IT OR
THAT NOW TRICKS ON AND THERE'S
ALSO AN INJECTABLE FORM OF THE
PEOPLE ARE FEW WHICH WE THINK
IS REALLY REALLY GOING TO TURN
THINGS AROUND- BUT THAT THERE
ARE GOOD EVIDENCE PASTRY. FOR
OTHER SUBSIDIES- DISORDERS THAT
WE HAVE MEDICATIONS WHICH WORK
WELL FOR OPIATES AND WE HAVE
MEDICATIONS WHICH WORK WELL FOR
AL ALL WE HAVE NOTHING FOR
METHAMPHETAMINE OR STIMULANTS
LIKE COCAINE WE HAVE NOTHING
FOR CANNABIS- IN FACT THERE ARE
GOOD EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT
WHICH DID NOT INVOLVE A DOCTOR
OR PRESCRIPTION- CONTINUE TO
MANAGEMENT WHICH IS AS IT
SHOULD. THE PROGRAM DOES NOT
NEED A DOCTOR TO DO A PRETTY
GOOD EVIDENCE THAT WORKS WELL
IN STIMULANTS- SO
METHAMPHETAMINES WORKS BETTER
THAN ANYTHING ELSE WE'VE HAD.
WE HAVE WE HAVE OTHER EVIDENCE
BASED TREATMENTS WHAT WE THINK
THAT WITH MY INSURER WILL BE A
LOT OF THE- THE BAD APPLES A
LOT OF THE ABUSE THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES. BUILT. FOR MILLION
LITTLE NOISE WAS JUST HERE IN
ORANGE COUNTY. WE THINK THAT
THIS THIS THE LICENSING MOBILE
AND A LOT OF. BECAUSE THE
TREATMENT PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO
GET A LICENSE ARE GONNA HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH STATE. AND IF THEY
COMPLY WITH STATE THERE'S THE
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE BILL
YOU KNOW. ELEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS A POP FOR A URINE TEST
WHICH CAUGHT TWENTY BUCKS AND
THREE TIMES A WEEK. AND BILL
YOU KNOW MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS WE ALL KNOW EXIST.
SO WITH. OUR WORK WE'RE IN VERY
MUCH IN FAVOR OF LICENSURE- AND
AN INCREASING OVERSIGHT WE
THINK THIS IS A GOOD THING THIS
WILL HELP PEOPLE. THIS WILL
KEEP PEOPLE ALIVE. ARE WE
OFFERING MEDICATIONS
PARTICULARLY NOW IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE HAD. INCREASING ABOUT
THAT NOTHING OF FENNEL IS NOW
ARRIVING HEALTH. IT WAS HERE
WAS NOT HERE EARLIER. IT'S
INCREASING WE'RE SEEING
INCREASING NUMBER AS FROM FAT
NOW. OUR PROBABLY THIS YEAR I
THINK FIRST YEAR RUN PIECE.
THAT METHAMPHETAMINE DOES WILL
NOW EXCEED OPIATE DESK
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE MORE
PEOPLE DYING FOR NEW FOR
METHAMPHETAMINE THAT WE HAVE
FROM OPIATES AND YOU'LL BE DOES
A RISING BECAUSE FENTON WAS NOW
ARRIVED. PILL FORM. AND SO THE
OTHER THE OTHER THING THAT THAT
IT IT CAME UP IN THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU SENT ME WORK HOW DO WE
HOW DO WE- YOU KNOW SO THAT WE
HAVE ANY MEDICATIONS WE HAVE AN
INJECTABLE FORM. THE
BUPRENORPHINE. AND THIS IS THIS
I THINK IS A REAL GAME CHANGER
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW. MANY
PEOPLE COME OUT OF TREATMENT
AND YOU SEE THEM- RIGHT RIGHT
WHERE WE SIT YOU SEE PEOPLE
COME OUT AND THEY PUT ON
MEDICATIONS IF THEY HAVE. A
HEROIN ADDICTION. AND THE SOBRE
LIVES WON'T TAKE A THE CAN'T IT
INTO A SOBER LIVING IF YOU'RE
ON THESE BUSES FOR THE MEASURE
NOT GEARED UP TO DISPENSE
MEDICATIONS. SO THEY COME OUT
OF TREATMENT STABLE WE CAN'T
GET HOUSING WE CAN'T GET IT WAS
OVER LIVING THEY GO BACK THE
STREET THE STOP THE MEDICATION
THEY WERE IS THE OVERDOSE. WITH
AN INJECTABLE FORM MEDICATION-
WE GIVE THEM A SHOT ONCE A
MONTH AND THE SOAP LIVINGS ARE
HAPPY BECAUSE THEY THEY CAN
STILL LIVE IN THEY COULD LEAVE
FOR AFTERNOON COME BY THE
OFFICE TO SEE THE NURSE COME TO
MY OFFICE GET A SHOP. AND GO
RIGHT BACK TO THE SOBER LIVING
THEY DON'T SO WILL NOT CHARGE
THE MEDICATION AND THEY CAN DO
THIS ONCE A MONTH. AND WE CAN
HOUSE PEOPLE WE GET PEOPLE OFF
THE STREET WHO WHO HAVE OPEN
TODAY. AND GET THE HOUSE WHICH
IS TO KEEP SOME SAFE KEEPS OF
DYING- WHICH WE THINK IS GOOD
IT WHICH WAS THE COULD BE WILL
HELP AND AT AS WELL AS THE
OTHER REJECTED ALL THE NOW
TRICKS. ON THE PATROL WHICH
ALSO WAS A BIG HELP WE HAVE
THAT AVAILABLE NOW. AND AS FAR
AS- THE OTHER QUESTION THAT WAS
ASKED. IS ABOUT HOW DO WE
FOLLOW PEOPLE. HOW DO WE KNOW
IF WE HAVE GOOD OUTCOMES. WERE
LICENSE TREATMENT FACILITIES
HOW DO WE KNOW. THAT A GOOD
JOB. AND STORE KLAY IT'S BEEN A
VERY DIFFICULT. TO TRACK YOU
KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
CHRONIC RELAPSING ILLNESS. AS
MY HYPERTENSION DIABETES ARE
YOU COULD FALL THEM YOU GO TO
THE LAB. AND INTO A BLOOD TEST
YOU CAN ACHIEVING YOUR OFF TO
TAKE THE BLOOD PRESSURE WITH
WITH PEOPLE WHO HAVE ALCOHOLISM
OR ADDICTIONS VERY FICKLE.
HISTORICALLY WE'VE YOU. DRUG
TESTING. WE USED THE
INTERACTIONS WITH THE LEGAL
SYSTEM YOU KNOW IF YOU DON'T
GET ARRESTED FOR A COUPLE YEARS
THIS IS USUALLY A SIGN THAT
YOU'RE NOT BACK IN THE DROP. UP
WE'VE USED ER VISITS AS SORT OF.
CIRCUIT MARKERS FOR DRUG USE
CHOOSE A LOT OF WAYS WE CAN
TEST BESIDES DRUG TESTING- IT
IT'S NOT A PERFECT SCIENCE A
IT'S A VERY. COMPLICATED
PROBLEM AND MANY PEOPLE REQUIRE
DIFFERENT- TREATMENT MODALITIES
TO GET- AND WE ARE YEAH MY
ORGANIZATIONS IN FAVOR. I THINK
EVERYTHING THAT WORKS WE JUST
WANT TO THAT ALL THINGS ARE
OFFERED A AT THE TRIAL LEVEL.
SO THAT'S IT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. SO THE COUPLE
QUESTIONS PRESS START AND YOU I
WITH YOU MISS IT A I SEE YOU
YOU COMMENTED IN YOUR TESTIMONY
THAT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY SHOCKED
AT JUST THE COMPLETE LACK OF
REGULATION AND OVERSIGHT OF
EITHER PROVIDERS OR AT AS
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT YEAH IT'S THE
ONLY STATE IT'S THE ONLY STATE
THAT YOUR ORGANIZATION OPERATES
IN THIS TOTAL LACK OF OVERSIGHT
AND IT IS A I HAVE BEEN EQUALLY
SHOCKED IS A YOU KNOW THIS IS
MY FIRST YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TO LEARN THAT IT'S
SHOCKING AND IT IS SHIPPING
FALL SO I'M QUESTION I THINK I
ASKED YOU WHEN WE'RE CHATTING
EARLIER BUT I'D LOVE UNIT YOU
SHARE WITH THE GROUP IS YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU LOOK ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHO IS DOING A GOOD
JOB. AND WHO AND WHERE CAN WE
LACK FOR NORTH STAR IT'S. WE
TRY TO PUT TOGETHER A FREE MORE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. YEAH IT OUT
THAT'S A GREAT XIN THERE IS A
LOT OF REALLY GOOD WORK BEING
DONE- WITH OUR STATE PARTNERS
IN AGENCIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE STATE OF MINNESOTA HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN THIS
IT IS AND THIS IDEA OF QUALITY
AND THE LICENSING REGULATIONS-
NEED OF THE- OF THE DEFAULTS
FOUR ON STATE AGENCIES AS
DOCUMENTATION RATE BUT-
DOCUMENTATION FOR DOCUMENTATION
SAKE AND QUALITY. SO WHAT WHAT
ARE INDICATORS OF QUALITY WELL
I'M YOU KNOW. INDICATORS OF
QUALITY ARE- PEOPLE THAT ARE
MEASURING THEIR OUTCOMES ARE
THEY ARE THEY MEASURING THEM-
WITH ADULT OBJECTIVE CRITERIA-
ARE THEY- YOU KNOW TING SOME OF
THE THINGS. THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT TODAY LIKE HAVING. YOUR
PROFESSIONAL PROVIDERS THAT ARE
EQUIPPED TO HANDLE OF THE COAL
CURRYING DISORDERS ARE APPARENT
IN YOUR NEARLY A 100% OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WE SEE- OUR
STATISTICS ARE OF THOSE TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT WE'RE-
TREATING A YEAR- WHEN WE LOOK
AT OUR EHR 90% OF THEM HAVE A
CO INCURRING. MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION THE DEPRESSION
ANXIETY DISSOCIATION SOMETHING
LIKE THAT SO YOU KNOW THIS IS-
THIS REQUIRES THE RIGHT TYPE OF
PROVIDER THE RATE TYPE OF
SERVICES EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES- THAT THE DOCTOR
TALKED ABOUT HERE EIGHT IS
SUPER IMPORTANT- ESTAS IN
QUALITY AND. SO YOU KNOW
MINISTER IS AB ABSOLUTELY-
SOMEBODY TO OR IN. THE NORTH
TEARS DURING THE TREMENDOUS JOB
AND WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THE ORGAN
SYSTEM ISN'T AT THEY HAVE
INVITED THE PUBLIC TO BE PART
OF THE CONVERSATION SO OUR
PREVIOUS PANELISTS TALKED ABOUT
HAVING PEOPLE IN THE RECOVERY
COMMUNITY. BE PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION AND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL THAT THAT-
THAT WE BRING IN EXPERTS- OF A
MEDICINE THAT WE BRING IN
EXPERTS FROM CLINICAL THAT WE
BRING IN EXPERTS FROM EVERY CAN
BE FROM THE SOBRE HOMES.
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE CREEK
CONTINUUM OF CARE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. AND THEN AB GEN I
HAVE FOR YOU DR. IN OUR
PREVIOUS ALL MENTIONED THE FACT
THAT THERE IS THE SMARTEST CAN
SOMEONE THERE CAN BE A
DYSFUNCTIONAL RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THOSE WERE PRACTICING
ADDICTION PRINCE OF OUR- OTHER
MEDICAL PRACTITIONERS AND THE
THIRD YOU KNOW KIND OF TREATING
THE IMMEDIATE SOMETIME RATHER
THAN LOOKING BACK AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S THE CAUSE WHAT CAN
WE DO TO FORGE A MORE EFFECTIVE
AND PRODUCTIVE RELATIONSHIP
THERE AND HAVE EVERYBODY.
WORKING TOGETHER MORE TO PLAY
SO THIS IS THIS IS A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN DR
PRACTICES DICTION AND DR THE
REST OF THE WORLD WHAT YOU HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND THAT ALMOST ALL
MY COLLEAGUES THINKS I'M NUTS I
MEAN YOU KNOW I AM IF PEOPLE
SEE YOU TAKE YOUR DRUG ADDICTS
ALCOHOLICS ARE YOU THINKING
ONCE SHE JUST. TAKE YOUR BLOOD
PRESSURE AND DIABETES OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO WE ARE
LOOKED AT RATHER ODDBALL YOU
KNOW WE ARE KIND OF OUT LIARS
AND PART OF THAT BECAME BECAUSE
MANY OF THE EARLY PIONEERS IN
ADDICTION TREATMENT CAME OUT OF
THE ROOM REMOVED SELF THEY WERE
IN RECOVERY AND THEY THEY CAME.
THEY WERE LIKE THE RADICS WE
WERE THE LAST PLACE TO PRACTICE
KNOWN AS ONE OF THEM SO YEAH
IT'S IMPORTANT WE DO A LOT OF
THAT REGION EDUCATION. WITH
WITH OPIATES I BEING WITH.
YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO REMOVE
STE I'M IN THE STATE IS A HUGE
PROBLEM IN THAT. PEOPLE DON'T
WANT TO TAKE CARE PEOPLE
WEBSITE THE STORE THEY DON'T
TAKE YOUR DRUG ADDICTS. AND SO
WE DO A LOT OF WORK
ORGANIZATIONS HE'S AS A LOT
ABOUT REGION IN AND GET FULL TO
COMMUNICATE. I THINK WITH THE
ADS OF ELECTRONIC RECORDS
THERE'S ALSO. THERE'S ALSO A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF FEDERAL.
PROHIBITION HEARING INFORMATION
SO THIS IS A OF HIPAA AND
THERE'S ENOUGH TO SEE FOR PART
TWO WHICH ARE TWO SEPARATE LAW.
FEDERAL LAW VERSUS STATE LAW
TERMS SHARING. SO IF I HAVE A-
SOME OF MY OFFICE AND I HAVE A.
A MONSTER BOX ON AND I SPEND
ALL DAY EVERY DAY IT TREATING
PATIENTS WITH IT WITH ADDICTION
ALCOHOLISM. I COLLEAGUES CAN'T
ALWAYS SEE THAT NOTE. SO IF I
SEND SOMEONE OVER TO GET IT IF
THEY HAVE A HERNIA AND I SEE
YOU NEED A HERNIA REPAIR I SEE
YOU NEED YOUR COLONOSCOPY AND I
SAID I'M OVER THAT IT'S HARD
SOMETIMES FOR THOSE DOCTORS
LOOK AT THE DATA BECAUSE THERE
ARE FEDERAL RULES THAT PROHIBIT
THE SHARING OF DATA WE OPERATE
A SILO. AND THE FEDERAL FEDERAL
LAW TRUMPS STATE LAW AND SO WE
HAVE TO WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
NOW THERE'S SOME FEDERAL
REGULATION BEING CHANGED TO
ALLOW SHARING INFORMATION BUT
SOME OF IT IS JUST LAW SAYS I
CAN'T. I CAN'T PUT STUFF ON A
CHART THAT ANOTHER DOCTOR CAN
SEE. QUESTIONS RATHER MEMBERS.
NOT A QUESTIONNAIRE IT REALLY
GO SIDE TO. JENNIFER WE'VE HAD
REALLY GOOD COMMUNICATION- WITH
STATE OF FLORIDA AND THE STATE
ATTORNEY UBER DAVE CURRENT
BURKE I BELIEVE WHAT SOLVE
THEIR SUCCESS WITHIN OF THE
BILLS THAT WE'VE TRIED IN YOU
KNOW GOD HIMSELF BUT NOT OVER
THE LINE INCLUDING KILEY PETER
IS THE LAST ONE. THAT HAVE YOU
HAD ANY. EXPERIENCE WITH THE
STATE OF FLORIDA AND EIGHTY
FORD OF BECAUSE- THEY PUT
TOGETHER A TASK FORCE WHICH I
THINK IS THE BEGINNING IN THE
LEGISLATURE FROM LAST YEAR WHEN
ASSEMBLYMAN. ARKADY HE JUST
WENT AWAY SO. I'M JUST GONNA
CALL YOU CARTY OKAY YOU CAN
CALL ME PAT. BAD TO IN ANY WAY
THAT SHE STARTED ABOUT I'M NOT
SURE WE HAVE ALL THE RIGHT
PEOPLE ON THERE THAT THEY HAD
ON THERE IS AND MAYBE THAT
SOMETHING THAT. WILL BE ON OUR
HER TO DO LIST FOR NEXT YEAR.
GET BACK TOGETHER BUT HAVE YOU
HAD ANY INTERACTION WITH THEM
BECAUSE ON THREE OF THE BILLS I
THINK THAT- WE'VE AUTHORED-
FEEL ABOUT FIVE DIDN'T MAKE IT
IT IT IT BACK THERE LIKE. MINE
DOES DECEPTIVE MARKETING
PRACTICES SOFTWARE WHEN. ON OUR
BECAUSE HE WAS PUT IN THE WRONG
PLACE AND HE ACTUALLY TO. AT
THE END OF IT. AND LEAVE OUT
WAS THE REASON THAT THE PARENTS
WERE LURED INTO THIS PARTICULAR
FACILITY WITH A- MARKETING AND
WE'RE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN ON IT CETERA ETCETERA AND
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN SO. YOU HAVE
ANY IDEAS ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE
DOING THAT WE MIGHT. TAKE WITH
A FIVE READ THE NEXT YEAR. YEAH
HE'S LINDA ACTUALLY THE
FACILITY IN FLORIDA AND THE-
FLORIDA SO- WE ARE WELL AWARE
OF THE- EVOLUTION. OF THE
REGULATIONS IN FLORIDA AND- YOU
KNOW REALLY THE- THE- THE
DECEPTIVE PRACTICES THAT YOU
TALK ABOUT TRANSFERRING HERE
TO. THERE IN CALIFORNIA- AND
THERE'S BEEN. A LOT OF WORK-
WITH THAT BROAD SECTION THAT I
TALKED ABOUT HAVING- EVERYBODY
IN THE ENTIRE CONTINUUM AT THE
TABLE WHICH ALSO INCLUDES LAW
ENFORCEMENT. I MEAN THIS IS A
COMMUNITY. FAMILY DISEASE AND
IT TAKES A COMMUNITY AND THE
FAMILY AND IF YOU KNOW WHICH
INCLUDES THE PROVIDERS IN THE
SCHOOLS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
TOGETHER TO SAUL. ON THIS IS A
REALLY COMPLEX ISSUE BUT ONE OF
THE YEAH WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
THE- THE PROSECUTORIAL ON
DETERRENCE. HELP IN FLORIDA YOU
KNOW THEY'RE NOT JUST PUTTING
LAWS IN PLACE BUT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY. ENFORCING THOSE LAWS
AND THEIR PUBLICIZING THOSE
LAWS AND- YOU KNOW I'LL EVEN
GIVE CREDIT OUTS THE MEDIA THE
MEAT I HAS BEEN. REALLY REALLY
GOOD AT- REPORTING ON SOME OF
THE ABUSES THAT THAT HAPPENED
IN SOUTHERN CAL- IT SOUTHERN-
FLORIDA AS WELL- AND SHINING A
LIGHT ON THE- ON THE NECESSITY
FOR THIS. YOU KNOW IT AND
UNFORTUNATELY- YOU KNOW UP AB
ABUSES LIKE THIS LATE DECEPTIVE
MARKETING PRACTICES- ADDICTION
TREATMENT- SEPARATE AND APART
FROM YOUR OTHER HEALTH CARE. IS
NOT CONTROLLABLE BY. ANYBODY
IT'S GENERALLY CONSUMER DRIVEN.
AND GENERAL WHEN YOU'RE IN A
STATE OF CHAOS. YEAH THE FAMILY
UNIT DOESN'T IN A STATE OF
CHAOS OR- THERE'S A LICENSURE
ISSUE THERE YOUR ATTORNEY OR OF
ITS- AIRLINE PILOT OR SOME
OTHER TYPE OF LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL. AND SO THE
FIREMAN'S IS A RIGHT FOR THAT
THOSE WITH THE FLASH'S WEBSITE.
TO CAPTURE THE GREATEST AMOUNT
OF ATTENTION AS OPPOSED TO IF
YOU HAVE DIABETES OR HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE OR SOME OTHER KIND OF
CONDITION. AND YOU HAVE A
NAVIGATOR THAT KNOWS THE SYSTEM
KNOWS WHERE- YOU CAN GO TO GET
THE BEST TREATMENT- BECAUSE YOU
KNOW TREATMENT WORKS AND
RECOVERY IS ABSOLUTELY
POSSIBLE. BUT IT GETS FUZZY
WITH. THIS YOU KNOW THESE
DECEPTIVE PRACTICES THAT ARE
HAPPENING SO ABSOLUTELY A
PARTNERSHIP AMONG ALL OF THESE
GROUPS IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY
IN LICENSING IS A BIG PART OF
IT I MEAN FLORIDA HAS LICENSING
FOR DIFFERENT LEVELS OF CARE.
AND THEY HAVE BACKGROUND CHECKS
FOR PROVIDERS. SO YOU KNOW WE
CAN GET THERE TOO. I AB NINE
TWENTY AND MY FOR BOTH WERE
VIDAK BUT BECAUSE OF THE ISSUE
OF IN FORCE I THINK THAT WAS
WHAT YOU BROUGHT UP IS THE AS
THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS. SEEM
TO ME WHAT WE NEED TO CONTACT
FIVE SOMETHING THAT PROVIDE.
ENFORCEMENT THAT MAYBE WE OUT.
TO THE LOW LEVEL WITH SOME
STATE PENDING OR MATCHING. I
KNOW LAW ENFORCEMENT IS GOING
TO BE SPEAKING LATER AND MIGHT.
DRESS THAT ISSUE BECAUSE BOTH
MALES IN PARTICULAR I THINK
NINE TWENTY WAS REALLY GOING AN
ODD GREAT DIRECTION THAT
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR'S
CONCERNED ABOUT COST OF
ENFORCEMENT IT GOT BE DOING IN
MY LISTEN MATTER OF REACHING
OUT TO A THIRD PARTY THAT MIGHT
BE DOING THE- ADVERTISING FOR.
AN HOUR. AN ORGANIZATION WE CAN
GO AFTER THE THIRD PARTY WOULD
HAVE TO BE THE SPECIFIC
PROVIDERS SO WE'LL WE'RE
WORKING ON OFFICE BECAUSE
THERE'S A PATH THERE I'M NOT
SURE ON SB I MEAN AB NINE.
TWENTY THERE WAS A PATHWAY
BECAUSE OF THE ENFORCEMENT
ISSUES SO. WE'RE PARTNERS WITH
YOU TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
GET THAT FUNDING FOR YOU ON
THAT BILL. THANK YOU DOCTOR SHE
THANKS I THINK WELL THE COST OF
ENFORCEMENT THE SUBSTANTIAL.
CLEARLY THE COST OF DOING
NOTHING MORE IS A LOT MORE YEAH.
I AND MY HAD A COMMENT I'M-
JUST COMMON ONE OF THE THINGS
AND- THESE. HEARING IN ARE
EITHER HELD IN THE DISTRICT UP
AT THE STATE. AND WE DO THE
PUBLIC THAT JOINS US HERE AND
SOMETIMES AT THE STATE IT'S
REALLY I THINK IN MANY WAYS
MEANT FOR THE LEGISLATORS TO
LEARN THE INFORMATION BECAUSE
UNLIKE OTHER INSTITUTIONS IT'S
NOT LIKE YOU GO TO- LEGISLATORS
SCHOOL YES YOU LEARN ABOUT
POLICY SO THANK YOU TO THE
SPEAKERS BECAUSE I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT YOU GET A
LITTLE BIT OF INFORMATION. AND
THEN EACH TIME I'M- YOU HEAR
ABOUT THE ISSUE YOU GAIN MORE
BUT CERTAINLY TO MY COLLEAGUES
THEY ALWAYS KNOW BILL NEVER
DIES SO I CERTAINLY EXPECT THAT
YOU'LL BRING UP THE BILLS THAT
WERE VETOED BACK WITH THE BUT I
ALSO THINK JUST FROM HEARING
THE PANELIST. AND WE'RE ALSO
HAVE ONE TO COME THE NEXT
PANELIST I'VE ALREADY HEARD IN
MY NOTES OPPORTUNITY FOR
LEGISLATION AND HAD I NOT
PARTICIPATED I MAY NOT HAVE
THAT FIRSTHAND. BUT I WILL SAY
THE ONE KEY WORD THAT I'M GOING
TO TAKE AWAY ALREADY FOR MY
WHAT I'VE HEARD IS STILL NOT.
AN AS WERE TALKING ABOUT
ADDICTION. IT GOES IT PAYS TO
ONE KIND OF IMAGE BUT IF YOU
TALK ABOUT SOMEBODY WITH THE
BREAST CANCER OR SOMEBODY. WITH
AS WE SAY DIABETES OR HEART
ATTACK IT GOES IN A DIFFERENT
WAY AND WHEN WE HAVE SOMEBODY A
NEIGHBOR OR A FAMILY MEMBER-
WE'VE JUST HEARD- THERE HAVE
REX BREAST CANCER WE START OUR
FACEBOOK GROUPS TO BRING MEALS
IN OUR CHURCH GROUPS AND-
SURROUND THEM WITH LOVE AND-
HUGS. BUT WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT
ADDICTION. IT BRINGS IN THIS
THING LIKE WHAT DID THAT FAMILY
DO WERE THEY NOT THERE. UP
MOTHER NOT THE RIGHT MOTHER ALL
OF THESE OTHER THINGS AND WHEN
WE SEPARATED MEDICALLY. I MEAN
IT IS A DISEASE ADDICTION AND
MENTAL HEALTH THOSE ARE A
DISEASES BUT AGAIN BECAUSE THE
WAY THEY ARE- THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM HAS FRAMED- IN MANY WAYS
THEY'RE TAUGHT IT'S SECONDARY
TO A HEALTH CONDITION. AND AS
WHAT I SEE HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND
IS ONE ISSUE LEADS TO ANOTHER
SO SOMEBODY MIGHT STRUGGLE WITH
FIRST WEATHER BE ALCOHOLISM OR-
ENDS BUT THEN THAT STARTS TO
DETERIORATE ON ONLY PHYSICALLY.
SO THEY HAVE OF COURSE HEALTH
ISSUE. BUT THEN MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES SO I AM MORE THAN EVER
MOTIVATED FOR US AS A TEAM UP
HERE TO CONTINUE TO BREAK DOWN
SOME OF THE INFORMATION THAT
THE PUBLIC RECEIVES. BUT ALSO
THAT WE CAN TAKE SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'VE GAINED
HERE AND DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT-
BECAUSE WE LOSE ALL TOO MANY
PEOPLE ARE UNDER UMBRELLAS THAT
WE PUT PEOPLE AND SO WHETHER
IT'S ADDICTION WHETHER IT'S
HOMELESSNESS. YOU KNOW AN
ORANGE COUNTY OVER THE LAST
YEAR WE HAVE LOST FOUR HUNDRED
PEOPLE JUST ST ORANGE. ORANGE
IN HOMELESS BUT HOW MANY OF
THEM ALSO WERE ADDICTED AND
HAVE HEALTH ISSUES AND SO
FORTH. SO I'M- LIKE I'M IN
PLACE. I AM EXACTLY EIGHT TO BE
ABLE TO AND I ACTUALLY I WAS
NOT SUPPOSED TO BE HERE I. WAS
ON A PLANNED TRIP IN BECAUSE OF
A MIGRAINE SO THERE'S ANOTHER I
HAD THE TURN SO I MEANT TO BE
HERE TODAY. SO GLAD YOU COULD
JOIN APPS AND DATA. Q. TO FOR
ALSO ASKING FOR BEING HERE
REALLY REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
HEIGHT AND ALL YOUR SUPPORT. AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. WITH THAT
LET'S GO AHEAD AND CALL UP OUR
THIRD PANEL ON THE. THE FOCUS
OF OUR THIRD PANEL IS LAW
ENFORCEMENT HOW CAN RESPOND TO
UNSCRUPULOUS OPERATORS WILL BE
HEARING FROM MAYOR KATRINA
FULLY. UP FRONT TRACY HUSING
WHO IS THE SENIOR SENIOR DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY HERE IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND FROM JEFF
POWELL ACT WHO IS THE ASSISTANT
SHARE. ALSO HEARING FROM. THE
FULLY WILL GO AHEAD AND START
WITH THAT WITH YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
FOR THANK YOU FOR AT LETTING US
HOSTS THIS IMPORTANT HEARING
HERE TODAY I JUST A LITTLE BIT.
EVAN INTRODUCTION SO. I GREW UP
IN IT WITH AN ABUSIVE
STEPFATHER WHO WAS AN ALCOHOLIC
MY MOM HAS BEEN SOBER SINCE I
WAS A TEENAGER BUT YOU KNOW SHE
GOT TO GO INTO SPACE OVER
LIVING HOME IN SANTA BARBARA
WAS CONNECTED TO COTTAGE
HOSPITAL WHERE- IT WASN'T ALL
ABOUT MONEY AND INSURANCE AND-
THANK YOU REALLY. IT WAS ABOUT
TRYING TO HELP THE WOMEN WHO
LIVED THERE SO THERE IS A PLACE
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND A NEED FOR
GOOD QUALITY OPERATORS BUT WHAT
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT AND WE'RE
GONNA START OUR SLIDESHOW OF
AREA- WHAT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IS WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
PARTICULAR IN OUR COMMUNITY
THAT HAS CAUGHT UP IN OUR CITY
TO SPEND APPROXIMATELY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS SO FAR IN
LITIGATION AGAINST ABUSIVE
SOBER LIVING HOME OPERATORS- SO
COSTA MESA. I YOU HEARD A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT EARLIER BUT
WE- GAVE IN WITH A NOW WE HAVE
EIGHT. IS THAT OUR STATE YES.
AND WHAT WHAT. DEAN. IS A SET
FROM A CROSS THE COUNTRY
AGGRESSIVE ARE ADVERTISED IN
FOR THAT. BE HAPPY RIVIERE.
SURE NO PROBLEM THE BILL PAY
FOR YOU SURE NOTES. THEY WILL
BUY A ONE WAY TICKET- BUT
RETURN SO WE END OF CREATING AN
ORDINANCE AND WE'VE UPDATED
THAT ORDINANCE A COUPLE OF
TIMES SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN EXCITED. OF SO OUR
ORDINANCE WE BELIEVE IS A GOOD
MODEL AND IT IS A COMMONSENSE
LAW I'VE BEEN IT'S AN TAX. IN
THE ASSEMBLY HALL AS WELL. HE
IF I HAVE IT SEX OF YOUR FILE
FELL IS DEAL FROM OPERATING
LIVING WE HEARD CARE FOR PANEL
BUT THAT GOODS. IT PROVIDES
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SUPER VISION
APP PATIENTS. EVENTS BEING AN
ORDINANCE AS YOU CAN THAT.
MYERS AT IF BY THAT INTO IT
TRANSPORTATION THE FIRST TO COP
TO ASSUME THERE SOMEONE I'M-
YOU HAVE. AS FOR THEIR RETURN
GO BACK HOME THEIR SUPPORT WORK
AND FAMILY. WE HAVE A NOTE SEE
AN NEIGHBOR POLICY. WE HAVE A
MEASURE THAT. DISTANCE REMEDY
THAT PREVENT IS TO SHIP SAGE OF
REPRESENTS SPACE REQUIREMENTS
SIX FIFTY IT UP AND THEN WE'RE.
IT CAN TO PROTECTING THE
CHANCE. THE CHARACTER OF THE
CITY'S EVER HEADS THAT WE GO
BACK TO THE COMMENTS FROM CELL
IS IT SAL ABOUT. THE COMMUNITY
AND BUILD A POSITIVE PLACE NEXT.
OUR OBJECTIVES WERE- TO
ENCOURAGE OPERATOR FIRST. THE
GOOD OPERATOR TEXAS VISUAL
RECORD THREE THE REST COMES
CLEAN COVER FIRE AND THE NEW
MINIMIZE PRIME THE WAY DRUG USE
AND SURE PEOPLE COVER YOU CAN
LIVE. COOPER FIRST DO SO I
THINK BE HEARD HERE TODAY.
WHITE PEOPLE OKAY THERE'S NO
REGULATION HOWEVER NOTE OVER
EIGHT TO LIVE ON FOR CRAP THANK.
HE'S FOR SEX OFFENDERS WE SENT
ONE FEDERAL COURT CASE. JUSTIN
JACK WHERE THEY WHERE ONE OF
THE. I OP INSTEAD WAS THAT THEY
THOUGHT THAT OR IS THAT WOULD
ALLOW SEX. TWO SEVEN. THAT
ORDER IS THIS WE'RE TRYING TO
PROTECT PEOPLE SAID. DISAGREED
THEM FORTUNATELY I'M COMING.
I'M PRETTY SURE FRAUD AND THEN
OF COURSE MEDICATION MAN
RESULTING IN A XIN FOR DOES
DEATH AND THESE ARE NOT ALL
SPECULATIVE THIS IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING. NEXT SLIDE. WE HAVE
SEVEN THE SERVER LIVING HOME
LAWSUIT THAT ARE CURRENTLY
STILL TING. ALL ARE. I'M MORE
IN FEDERAL COURT RIGHT NOW
WE'VE HAD A WE HAD A HIGHER
DESPITE LIES EFFORT. HE TO
HANDLE THIS THE XIN BREATH. AND
WE HAVE. AN EXTRA SEVEN IS
LITIGATION AND COVERAGE. WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED WHAT WE LEARNED
THAT PEOPLE SUFFERING FROM
ADDICTION ARE VULNERABLE TO
EXPLOITATION ABOUT OPERATORS I
THINK EVERY THE PANEL THEY HAVE
AS THAT. READERS WILL STOP
NOTHING RIGHT RIGHT THE SHIN
DIG INTO CYCLE EXPLOITING THEIR
VICTIMS MANSION AND WE HEARD.
ALL OF THE PAST AS TO ARE
WORKING IN THESE INDUSTRIES A
THEY'RE NOT AFRAID REGULAR. I'M
AFRAID OF LIFE THANK YOU SOME
ART I'M THOSE FIRST YEAH THANKS
BYE SEVEN ARE YOURS BECAUSE
THEY WANT US TO HAVE A IN
ORDER. THE THIRD. DROP
REPRESENT THIS BUT WELCOME
RIGHT TIONS. US SO WE I'M NOT
GONNA GO THROUGH ALL OF THIS
INDIVIDUALLY BUT WE DID- WE'VE
IDENTIFIED WE HAVE EVIDENCE OF
HARM INDUSTRY PRACTICE YOU KNOW
THE RECYCLING OF PATIENTS THIS.
IDEA THAT IT'S A MODEL OF
RELAPSE INSTEAD OF BEING A
MODEL OF RECOVERY IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT NEVER GOING TO A
RESTAURANT IF WE IF WE DON'T
BREAK THIS AT. THIS AT GOAL. I
LOVE TO LAUGH. FOR MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT I THINK THAT DR
INDEED IT THAT NO ONE SHOULD BE
SCRAPPED. I THINK HE'S THAT YOU.
SEN. LIMÓN BUT THERE IS AN
EIGHT SOME SEVEN. THERE ARE
TRADE PERFECT. AND WE ARE DYING.
SURE BROUGHT MONEY LAUNDERING
OPERATOR OUR FAULT SO FAR. IN
TERMS TO TRIGGER BRIDGE SERVER
IS RIGHT THERE IN THE. PATIENT
BROKER. U. S. G. NORRIS FOR
YOUR BILL AB IN NINETEEN THAT
EXIST FORCED TOOL TO ADD
SENATOR- AS OF AN- APPROPRIATE.
BUT THAT. AND WE JUST HEARD. I
KNOW IT IS A FROM RECEIVE
JESTER AS THE EXTENT OF
RESEARCH AND WRITING ON FISH
THE CURBING AND WHAT WE'RE
FIGHTING AT THAT. TWENTY SIX
PER CENT OF RESIDENTS WERE
LIVING IN OUR HOME. SHELVE ARE
PEOPLE FROM. ADDICTION
TREATMENT OF THE REASON THAT IF
YOU CROSS. OUT WE SEE EXPOSURE
OF PEOPLE THOMAS I WOULD NOT BE
SURPRISED ISN'T THIS HOW DO
KLAY RELATED BETWEEN THESE.
CURBING PEOPLE EXCITED. HOW DO
THEY RECYCLE PATIENTS BASICALLY
THE PATIENT ENTERS THE FACILITY
AND THEN THERE'S THE REHAB IS
THIS THE READ THE LIVING THIS
IS MONEY FROM THE INSURANCE
COMPANY. AND THEN. THEY HAD NOT
DAIS DAY THE TRICK IS AND THEN
SOME THE PATIENTS ARE EXPOSED
TO DRUGS AND IN OUR TO GET
BANDS WE HAVE TO COVER THAT
THERE ARE A WHOLE RIGHT WAY
THAT THERE'S THIS MATTER
EXPOSURE. TO THESE PATIENTS IN
ADDITION. TO GET TO COME BACK
TO THE FIRST THE AND START THE
CYCLE ALL OVER AGAIN AND THAT
IS THE MARK OF REAL APPS. I'M
NOT RECOVER A SIDE. I'M THE
DRUG STATE INSURANCE FRAUD. IN
OUR BRIEF. HAS IT TWICE IF YOU
THREE TWO WEEKS I THINK. TO THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW ONE IS
PRETTY MUCH FISH NO THESE ARE
DRUGS IF YOU WERE USING IF DO
IT TWICE YOUR I GET THE MEMBER.
THE END. ADDITION NOT ONLY ARE
THEY. ESTATE AND WE HAVE DIRECT
EVIDENCE OF THAT MULTIPLE TIMES
THEY'RE ALL SO USING THE
SAMPLES IN THERE SOMEHOW
CONNECTED TO THE LAB AND
THEY'RE GETTING A PAYMENT FROM
THE LAB AS WELL SLIDE. SO THAT
BECOMES THIS WHOLE. INSURANCE
ARE THE GAMES THAT HAPPENING
THERE. SAM OR TAKE FROM WHAT IF
IT WOULD BE IF AND THEY'RE TO
ANOTHER LAB THEN MY SIT BACK TO
THE FACILITY WE WERE IN CAMP
WAS WERE TAKE. THE ALL THE
GROUPS BOB. AFFECT OFF IS YOUR
TESTS AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE NEEDS LIKE.
WORK ON THIS AS AN ENFORCEMENT
COMPONENT EXCITED. I'M THE
INSURANCE COMPONENT WHAT WE'RE
FINDING IS THAT I'M. THERE'S
THREE SENT MARK THE SITE THAT
THE- THE WHAT I HAVE OVER
LOOKED COMES CONNECTED TO
TREATMENT CENTER. AND SO. HE
MADE SEVERAL COME AND COLLECT
THE MONEY. FOR EXAMPLE BECAUSE
INSURANCE IS. TREAT SENT HER
AND IT IS CENTER IS KING. BACK
TO THE LIVING WHICH. HE DOESN'T
KNOW THE THEY DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT PAYMENT IS BEING MADE TO
SO. ANOTHER SERIOUS I INSURANCE
CONCERNED THAT I DO HOPE THAT
THE STATE LOOKS INTO YOU NEXT
SLIDE. AS WE TALKED EARLIER
MEDICATION MANAGED ON A FIGHT
PEOPLE. CATION AND NOT VERY
DRESSED FIVE. SO THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT WE HAVE LEARNED AS
PART OF OUR LITIGATION OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND IT'S NOT
SPECULATIVE IT'S NOT BASED ON
DISCRIMINATORY- BELIEVES IT
BASED ON. ABOUT ABUSIVE
OPERATORS TRYING TO EXPLOIT
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS AND ALSO
JUST MAKE AS MUCH MONEY AS
POSSIBLE OFF OF THE INSURANCE
SO I AM SO GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK- YOU THREE WOMEN HAVE
DONE GREAT WORK TO HELP US ADD
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES THE
LICENSING ISSUES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN SHARON QUIRK
SILVA FOR PARTNERING WITH ME A
COUPLE YEARS AGO TO. ADDRESS
LIES SAYING AND THANK YOU. HI
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR HELPING NOW
AND WE SUPPORTED AB NINE TWENTY
WHERE WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
TAKE SOME FURTHER PROGRESS
WITH. AND SENATOR IT'S THANK
YOU FOR YOUR YEARS OF EFFORTS
SPACE AS WELL KATE ALL THAT
WORK AND WE'RE HERE TO PROVIDE
OUR STAFF AND OUR- WE HAVE A
LOT OF INFORMATION THAT IT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL TO YOU
THAT. THAT ACTUALLY IS THE DATA
THAT GOES TO THESE FLIGHTS.
THANK YOU MAYOR FALLING. I
BELIEVE TO ADDRESS HUGHES. SO
I'M TRACY HERE THANK YOU I'M A
SENIOR DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
AT THE ORANGE COUNTY DA'S
OFFICE I'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH
OUR OFFICES SOBER LIVING
ADDICTION TREATMENT TASK FORCE
SINCE IT STARTED AND I WAS THE
PRIMARY DRAFTER AT DICTION
TREATMENT REGISTRATION AND
DISCLOSURE ORDINANCE THAT WAS
PASSED BY. THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS LAST NOVEMBER. OUR
OFFICE IS COMMITTED TO FIGHTING
FRAUD RELATED TO THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC. MISTER SPITZER
UNDERSTANDS THAT UNSCRUPULOUS
OPERATORS ARE TARGETING
VULNERABLE PATIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND NEIGHBORHOODS ARE
SUFFERING DUE TO THE HUGE
PROLIFERATION OF SUB PAR
FACILITIES. WE HAVE A CASE
RIGHT NOW AND THE FIVE LARGEST
MANUFACTURERS OF PRESCRIPTION
OPIOIDS AND WE FELT THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WE HAVE A
TRIAL DATE JUNE OF NEXT YEAR
FOR DECEPTIVE MARKETING
PRACTICES CONTRIBUTING TO THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC. AND OUR OFFICE
NOW HAS ALLOCATED SEVEN PEOPLE
TO THE SOBER LIVING TEAM
ADDICTION TREATMENT TASK FORCE.
AND I JUST WANNA SAY A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT HOW THIS IS DIFFERENT
THAN OTHER CASES WE HANDLE AND
OUR OFFICE NORMALLY WE GET
REFERRALS FROM POLICE AGENCIES
SO IF THERE'S A SEXUAL ASSAULT
OR AND HOMICIDE OR SOMETHING.
THE POLICE AGENCY WILL
INVESTIGATE THAT CASE THE
DETECTIVES GO OUT. I DO ALL THE
INVESTIGATION THEY BRING IT TO
OUR OFFICE FOR FILING. WE FOUND
THE CASE AND WE TAKE THE CASE
TO TRIAL SO THEY ARE THE
PRIMARY ON THE GROUND
INVESTIGATORS FOR THOSE CASES.
AND OUR INVESTIGATORS ASSIST
AND ARE BRINGING THE CASE TO
TRIAL IN PROSECUTING THE CASES
AND MAYBE SOME FOLLOW UP. BUT
FOR THESE CASES BECAUSE THEY'RE
SO COMPLICATED AND SO DIFFERENT
THAN ANYTHING ELSE THAT WE
TYPICALLY SEE. WE ARE WORKING
ON THESE CASES FROM THE INSIDE
SO OUR TEAM IS INVESTIGATING
THESE CASES FROM THE GROUND UP
FRONT TIPS WE HAVE WE'VE HAD I
THINK A HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
TENTHS TO THE TIP LINE SO FAR.
AND THEY ARE BUILDING THESE
CASES INVESTIGATING THESE CASES.
PREPARING THEM FOR PROSECUTION.
THAT'S A REALLY DIFFERENT
ANIMAL AND IT'S VERY RESOURCE
INTENSIVE- A COUPLE OF THE
CASES THAT WE HAVE ON GOING ONE
WAS FILED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND INVOLVES. YOU
COULD HAVE TAKEN IRAQ FROM OUR
CASE AND THE SCHEMATIC THAT.
FOLEY SHOWED YOU IT INVOLVED A
URINALYSIS SCHEME AND THEY'RE
ACTUALLY WE HAVE ALLEGED AT
TESTING SOBER LIVING RESIDENTS
YEAR AND MULTIPLE TIMES A DAY
NOT ACTUALLY SENDING IT TO THE
LAB BUT BILLING INSURANCE FOR
THE TASKS- MULTIPLE TIMES AND I
THINK THE AGGREGATE AMOUNT OF
LOSS WAS TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. SO TWO OF THOSE AT
DEFENDANTS HAVE PLED GUILTY ONE
HAS PASSED AWAY AND THERE TO
THAT ARE AWAITING TRIAL. SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE CASES THAT ON
GOING I ANOTHER'S. SCHEME THAT
THE TEAM INVESTIGATED FROM THE
GROUND UP AND AGAIN VERY
COMPLICATED MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
ENTITIES LOTS OF DIFFERENT
PLAYERS. AND NOT WAS THE SERVER
LIFE USA CASE. THAT WAS FILED
LAST YEAR THEIR LEVIN
CODEFENDANTS AND THAT INVOLVES-
FRAUDULENT SURGICAL PROCEDURES.
THAT THEY WERE TELLING PAGE
PATIENTS WE HAVE ALLEGED I THAT
WOULD ADDRESS THEIR OPIOID
ADDICTION BUT THIS IS A NON FDA
APPROVED TREATMENT WHEREBY THEY
SURGICALLY IMPLANTED ON TRUCKS
AND PALLET IN PEOPLE. NOT FDA
APPROVED- AND THEY WERE
CHARGING THEY WERE GIVING WE
HAVE A LEADS TO THE PATIENTS
ABOUT A THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH.
AT TO COME IN AND UNDERGO THE
PROCEDURE THEN BILLING THE
INSURANCE COMPANY UP TO FORTY
THOUSAND A POP FOR THESE PEOPLE
COMING IN. SO THEIR LEVIN CO
DEFENDANTS IN THAT CASE TWO OF
THEM HAVE PLAYED GUILTY THE
REST ARE ON THEIR WAY THROUGH
THE SYSTEM AND I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AGAIN SO. OUR
INVESTIGATORS IN OUR TEAM PUT
THESE CASES TOGETHER. BUT
THEY'RE ALSO HAVING TO ASSIST
IN THE PROSECUTION SO THAT
MEANS GETTING THEM READY FOR
PRELIMINARY HEARING AND TRIAL.
SO WITH EACH ADDITIONAL CASE IN
OUR OFFICE COMES ALL OF THE
WORK ASSOCIATED WITH PUTTING
THOSE CASES ON. SO IT'S VERY
RESOURCE INTENT INTENSIVE AND
WE WOULD WELCOME ASSISTANCE
FROM OTHER LINE FORCE IN IN.
HELPING TO BUILD THESE CASES
ONE OF THE THINGS WE LEARNED
FROM TALKING TO OUR COLLEAGUES
IN FLORIDA. WELL AS THEY HAVE
ASSEMBLED A TEAM INSIDE THE
STATE'S ATTORNEY'S OFFICE OF.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WERE
HELPING WITH THE INVESTIGATION.
AND BUILDING IN THESE CASES.
I'M. SO OUR OFFICE IN MISTER
SPITZER UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH FRAUD
IN THE INDUSTRY ARE COMPLEX.
AND HE IS COMMITTED TO VIGOROUS
PROSECUTIONS OF THE CASES WITH
THE TOOLS WE HAVE. BUT AT. WHEN
ECHO WHAT WE'VE HEARD ON THE
PANEL TODAY THAT THIS IS A VERY
COMPLICATED AREA AND IT
REQUIRES A COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTIONS ARE NOT JUST
PROSECUTIONS ENFORCEMENT BUT
ALSO. MORE ROBUST REGULATIONS
SO THAT WE HAVE THE TOOLS FOR
THOSE PROSECUTIONS AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF STANDARDS SO
THAT FAMILIES WHEN THEY'RE
EVALUATING HOW THEY CAN GET
HELP FOR THEIR LOVED ONES THEY
CAN DECIDE IS THIS IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT WILL WILL HELP
THEM OR NOT AND RIGHT NOW. WE
DON'T HAVE THOSE THINGS SO I'M
IN THAT SECOND PRONG OF
LEGISLATION WE APPLIED. FELICE.
ORDINANCE AND ALSO WE WORKED ON
THIS ADDICTION TREATMENT. JUST
REGION ORDINANCE THAT WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR AND IT IS NEAR
AFTER I HAVE LAW AS FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZED THAT
THIS IS A VULNERABLE GROUP OF
PATIENTS AND WE NEED TO HAVE
EXTRA PROTECTIONS IN PLACE SO
IN SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
PART OF THE LICENSING PROCESS
REQUIRES THEM TO DISCLOSE
OWNERSHIP INTEREST IN OTHER
ENTITIES SO IF YOU. RECALL THAT
SLIDE WITH THE DIFFERENT THE
LAB IN THE DIFFERENT ENTITIES
IT'S COMMON FOR THESE
UNSCRUPULOUS OPERATORS TO HAVE
OWNERSHIP INTEREST IN ALL OF
THOSE PIECES SO THEY'RE
COLLECTING AT EVERY STAGE AND
THE PATIENT AND THE FAMILY
DOESN'T KNOW THAT THAT'S
HAPPENING SO. OUR ORDINANCE
TRIED TO SHINE A LIGHT ON THAT
AS WELL AS HAVING THE REGISTER
SO WE HAVE. AN IDEA OF JUST USE
OPERATING OUT THERE. I'M. SO
THREE PRONGED APPROACH ECHOING
WHAT THE PANEL SAYS I WE HAVE
BEGAN TO TALK WITH STAKEHOLDERS
I SEE SOMEONE FROM SAFER OUR
ACTS WHICH IS THE- SUBSTANCE
ABUSE. HI ANTI PRESCRIPTION
DRUG ABUSE TEAM WE HAVE AN
ORANGE COUNTY THAT YOU SEE I
STARTED IN THE AUDIENCE. HELLO
DOCTOR AND WE ARE TRYING TO
REACH OUT WITH AND TALK TO
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO TRY TO
WORK ON. HOPING WITH THE
STANDARD PIECE OF THIS THAT
WERE READY TO PROSECUTE CASES
AND WE ARE ACTIVELY WORKING ON
THEM. THANK YOU. AND ASSISTANT
SHERIFF POWER. ONE THANK YOU UP
MY NAME IS JEFF ALEC I AM THIS
IS SYSTEM SHERIFF I OVERSEE OUR
FIELD OPERATIONS AND
INVESTIGATIONS COMMAND WITH THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY ONE PATRON
ORDERS FOR INCLUDING US THIS
THIS PANEL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M HAS ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED
THROUGHOUT. THE DAY MANY THE
CITIES ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED BY THE PREVALENCE OF
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITIES. I'M GONNA TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE AND SHARE THE
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THE
CITY'S SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
JURISDICTION. I'M SURE WITH YOU
THE PERSPECTIVE FROM OUR LINE
LEVEL TROLL DEPUTIES THAT ARE
RESPONDING TO CALLS FOR
SERVICE. SO FOR CITY LIKE THE
HIGHLIGHTS THE CITY OF SAN
KHAMENEI AS FROM WHAT WE'RE
AWARE OF TWENTY FIVE
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT HOMES.
SEVENTEEN OF THOSE TWENTY FIVE
HOMES. RECEIVED ONE MORE CALLS
FOR SERVICE IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS. ONE HOME IN PARTICULAR
HAS AT THIRTEEN CALLS FOR
SERVICE. IN THAT TWO YEAR
PERIOD AND ONE HOMES HAD
SEVENTEEN WAS FOR PURPOSE AND A
TWO YEAR PERIOD. OF THE CITY OF
BEING A POINT IS A PARTNER TO
THE NORTH ON THEY HAVE OVER
THIRTY HOMES THAT WERE AWARE.
HALF OF WHICH OF HAD CALL OR
HAD MULTIPLE CALLS FOR SERVICE
IN THAT SAME TWO YEAR PERIOD.
THE TYPES OF CALLS TO RECEIVE
THESE HOMES RUN THE GAMUT AND
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT THE ONLY
OF LIFE IN THAT NEIGHBORHOOD.
WELL THE IMPACTS TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD MAYBE STE MADE
SIGNIFICANT THE FORCE OF LAW IS
OFTEN NEARLY A CITATION OR A
NUISANCE VIOLATION. THE LACK OF
ENFORCEMENT MEASURE LEAVES
NEIGHBORS POWERLESS TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEMS POSED BY THESE
BUSINESSES. IN ADDITION TO THE
IMPACTS TO RESIDENTS AREAS.
IMPROPERLY RUN TREATMENT
FACILITIES A FEW ARE HOMELESS
AND ADDICTION IS INDIVIDUALS
WHO FELT PROGRAMS OFTEN BECOME
TOMORROW'S HOMELESS. THE MORE
FRUSTRATING THINGS FOR
RESIDENTS IS A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND BE TOLD NOTHING CAN BE DONE.
TEARS FORMER WILL ISSUE
CITATIONS WILL CONTINUE TO
RESPOND TO CALLS- WILL WORK TO
RESOLVE PROBLEMS BUT WITHOUT A
PROPER REGULATORY BACKBONE. FOR
THE STREET EFFORTS CANNOT BE
SUCCESSFUL. WE'RE LOOKING FOR
TO IMPLEMENTATION OF AB NINETY
NINE NINETEEN AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THAT YOU NORRIS
WHICH REQUIRES THAT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO ESTABLISH AN
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM. PREVENT
AND STOP BODY BROKERING SCHEMES
WE ALSO HOPE THAT THE GOVERNOR
WILL RECONSIDER SUPPORTING THE
PRINCIPLES BEHIND EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY WHICH REQUIRES.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
PROGRAMS TO BE LICENSE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. REGULATION AND
ENFORCEMENT OVER SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT INDUSTRY. IS
VITAL AS WE CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE THE IMPACTS OF AN
OPIOID EPIDEMIC. CONTINUE TO
SEE A HIGH PREVALENCE OF GOITRE
IN ORANGE COUNTY. IN PARTICULAR
FEDERAL LEVEL ONCE CONTINUES TO
GROW. AS WE WORK TO COMBAT THIS
ADDICTION CRISIS WE NEED A BUS
SINCE ABUSE TREATMENT INDUSTRY
THAT IS BOTH ETHICAL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THEIR NEIGHBORS
WE KNOW OUR MANY GOOD
FACILITIES THAT EXISTS BUT WHEN
TO CONTINUE OUR EFFORT TO
REGULATE OUT THAT ACTORS. SURE
BARNES RECOGNIZE IS ALL SCHOOL
WHICH HAS BEEN REITERATED ON
THE PANEL THAT THIS IS A VERY
VERY COMPLICATED. SITUATION
COMPLICATED TO SAUL BUT HE'S
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT BUT WE AS LONG
COURSE OF MUST STRIKE A BALANCE
BETWEEN. THE OBLIGATION TO
MAINTAIN QUALITY OF LIFE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WE SERVE.
THANKS AND SO. QUESTION ALL OF
YOU KNOW I'M- PRETTY OPEN AND
MAYBE JUST GIVE ME THAT THE TOP
ONE OR TWO THINGS THAT WE CAN
WE DO AS STATE POLICYMAKERS TO
HELP. YOU DO YOUR WORK MORE
EFFECTIVELY. THERE'S THREE
THINGS DO ONE YOU COULD WORK
WITH THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
TO PRESS THE INSURANCE ABUSES
AND- SO THAT CITIES ARE
BURDENED WITH. REVENUE AND THE
TAX CONSEQUENCE HAVING USE OUR
MONEY TO PAY FOR THAT. TO
CERTAINLY A LIGHT SING AND
PERMITTING AND READY TORY
SCHEME THIS CALL GOAL TO THIS
INDUSTRY. AND OF THREE ALLOW
LOCAL ENTITIES TO REGULATE
WHICH RIGHT NOW THAT IS CAUSING
A LOT OF LITIGATION AS THERE IS
THIS TENSION BETWEEN EXACTLY
CAM LOCALS REGULATE VERSES WHAT
IS. PREEMPTED BY STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IN FLORIDA
THEY WERE ABLE TO GET PAST THE
BODY BROKERING LÀ BUT IT'S
FELONY AND THEY HAVE THEY HAVE
AN ASSEMBLY LINE OF THE BROKERS
THAT THERE. IN THROUGH AND
THEY'RE REALLY IMPACTING THEIR
RATES SO ANYTHING YOU DO IN
SACRAMENTO TO. IF SOME OF THESE
NEW LAST AND TEETH WOULD HELP
US AS PROSECUTORS. I THINK THAT
ARE YOU OR SOMEONE ELSE SAID
THAT THAT YES THE PROSECUTION.
PROSECUTORIAL DETERRENCE IN
FLORIDA HAS MADE AN ADAM
MEANINGFUL IMPACTS YEAH. THE
MOST IT'S BEEN HIT SO FAR BUT I
WOULD SAY THAT PROPER
REGULATORY BACKGROUND IS P.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE- I WOULD ALSO
SAY OR THE TO DETERMINE ALSO
MENTIONED ABOUT NEEDING HELP
YOU KNOW ANY TYPE OF FUNDING
FOR PERSONAL TO DO WHETHER IT'S
A TASK FORCE MODEL OR SOMETHING
WE CAN- RESOURCES SPECIFICALLY
TO. THIS TYPE OF ENFORCEMENT
THE LOCAL LEVEL WE'RE HELPFUL
IN RIGHT NOW WORKS IT'S JUST
NOT A LOT OF TEETH THERE'S NOT
A LOT WE CAN DO FROM A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVE OTHER
THAN RESPOND TO THOSE. DAY
TODAY CALLS FOR SERVICE
TYPICALLY A QUALITY OF LIFE I
CALLS ON WHETHER BE ABOUT MUSIC
OR PEOPLE IN CARS OR-
DISTURBANCES A PERSPECTIVE
THINGS IN AROUND THESE STEPS
PHONES. THE THING I'M FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT I THINK IF WE GET
IT ABLE TO GET THE RECALL AS AS
AS IN THESE ISSUES AND DRIVE
OUT THESE PREDATORY OPERATORS
NEEDS UNSCRUPULOUS ACTOR. SOME
OF THIS CAN THESE ANCILLARY.
CONCERNS WILL GO AWAY. CAN I
ALSO ASK. THE LICENSING
SPECTERS I KNOW THAT ASSEMBLY
WOMAN- QUIRKS BUT WORKED ON
TRYING TO GET US ONE IN ORANGE
COUNTY. I KNOW THE GOVERNOR
ADDED MORE MONEY FOR MORE
INSPECTORS NO ONE IN ORANGE
COUNTY. AND SO WHAT'S HAPPENING
IS OUR CODE ENFORCEMENT ARE-
SHERIFF'S OFFICERS WE'RE HAVING
TO BE AND WITH THAT THE STAFF.
AND I WOULD HAVE BEEN ON THAT
AS WE LEFT OFF WITH THE-
LEGISLATION THAT WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO MOVE THROUGH AT THAT
TIME AS THE CHAIR WOULD NOT
ACCEPT IT RIGHT. THERE HAS BEEN
PROGRESS IS NOW WE HAVE A NEW.
CHAIR I THINK THERE'S MUCH MORE
OF A PUBLIC THAT'S EDUCATED ON.
THE STEPS WE NEED TO TAKE SO I
DO THINK WE CAN RE LOOK AT THAT
BUT I KNOW THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS WHEN THEY HAVE THEIR
COMPLIANCE OFFICERS IN ESSENCE
HEADQUARTERED IN SACRAMENTO FOR
THE ENTIRE STATE. DID A GOOD
ROUND ABOUT WELL WE PUT ONE IN
LOS ANGELES AND I HAVE. QUITE A
BIT FOR ME SAYING LOS ANGELES
CAN BE AN HOUR AND A HALF AWAY
DEPENDING ON TRAFFIC UP MAYBE
FORTY FIVE MINUTES BUT THAT IS
NOT BASED IN ORANGE COUNTY SO
WE STILL HAVE STEPS TO TAKE.
BECAUSE THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO
REASON THAT IF WE HAVE EIGHT
COMPLIANCE OFFICERS I BELIEVE
IT'S TEN NOW AT THE STATE THAT
YOU COULDN'T HAVE SOMEBODY IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE FIVE DAYS A
WEEK IT COULD SIMPLY BE. ONE
DAY A WEEK MAYBE AN ORANGE
COUNTY SOMEBODY ELSE AND SAN
DIEGO BECAUSE CERTAINLY. OTHER
COUNTIES ARE DEALING WITH SOME
OF THE SAME ISSUES SO ON NOW
THAT THERE'S BEEN A CHANGE AT
THE PARCHMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES. IN THE KEY POSITION I
THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE FORWARD IN
AN ESSENCE. CREATE A PATHWAY
THAT IT'S NEW AND VISIONARY.
SENATE DEBATE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR. OUR PANELISTS I'M
GONNA HAVE TO LEAVE THAT I JUST
WANT TO THANK ALL THE PANEL
MEMBERS OUT. NEEDING A OF ALL
EFFORTS THAT HAVE GONE FORWARD
I WAS JUST LOOKING AT THE
NUMBER OF BILLS AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO EIGHTEEN. WE
PROBABLY HAD TO CLOSE TO TWELVE
THIRTEEN ALL OF WHICH DIED IN
COVERED MANY OF THE TOPICS THAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY AND
THE THINGS THAT ARE NEEDED. SO
I THINK ARE MINE. THOSE OF US
WHO SERVE IN THE LEGISLATURE IN
YOUR HOUSE WE NEVER GIVE UP
WITH THAT YOU KNOW WE CAN TO.
REDUCE THE LEGISLATION THAT
RESPONSE TO THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE HEARD HERE THEY- ARE
TODAY AND BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING
THIS HEARING COMES MORE MORE
PUBLIC. I THINK WE GOT A LOT OF
A LOT MORE FORCE BEHIND US
SINCE WE- INTRODUCED SITE AND
COME UP WITH SOME NEW IDEAS
THAT CERTAINLY ARE GENERATED BY
DISCUSSIONS SO. THANK YOU AND-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA IS IN GREAT TO JOIN YOU
IN AND CERTAINLY ALL THE
PANELISTS IN MAYOR ON FOLEY
THANK YOU FOR POSTING FAN. I
THINK IT'S A GREAT THE RIGHT
DIRECTION CAN REALLY HELP THE
SCHOOL. AT ALL LEVELS LOCAL.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND CERTAINLY I
IN THE LEGISLATURE. I TOO WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A VERY BRIEF
CLOSING COMMENT THINKING ONLY
ALL THE PARTICIPATE TO HAVE
JOINED US FROM THE PUBLIC. I
MEAN THAT AS YOU INFORMATION WE
DO AS WELL. FOR THE LEADERSHIP
WITH NOT ONLY ON THE ASSEMBLY
SITE ASSEMBLY MEMBER KADI
PETERS NORRIS AND ON THE SENATE
SIDE WITH A SENATOR PAT BATES.
I WILL JUST READ. THESE WORDS
THAT I COUNT MY TAKE AWAY IS.
I'M NEVER IT'S NEVER TOO TOO
TOO LATE TO CONTINUE TO LEARN
BUT I'M SHOCKED. IT SHAMEFUL
AND IT'S STAY GREEN AND WHAT WE
SEE THAT IS RELATED TO THE
DICTION AND THE STIGMA THAT ARE
KEEPING FAMILIES SUFFERING IN
SILENCE MANY TIMES ALONE NOT
UNDERSTANDING NOW TO NAVIGATE A
BROKEN SYSTEM. AND MY BROTHER
BILLY STORY IS A STORY OF MANY
AND I KNOW THAT I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK- ENDLESS HOURS TO SEE
SOME RELIEF FOR THE FAMILIES
THAT SUFFER AND FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK.
OUR PANELISTS HERE I THINK. IT
IS. IT'S CLEAR TO ME I'M ON SO
MANY LEVELS I THINK WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IS INSURE THAT WE
HAVE A BETTER PARTNERSHIP AT
BETWEEN OUR FEDERAL OFFICIALS
LOCAL OFFICIALS STATE OFFICIALS
AND COUNTY OFFICIALS TO
ACTUALLY TACKLE THESE PROBLEMS
AND GET THIS DONE SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP AND FOR
ALL YOUR WORK ON THAT. I'M NOT
BEFORE WE OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT WE I WOULD LIKE TO
BRING UP THE FINAL PANEL IS TO
IS GOING TO PART OF OUR FIRST
COMMITTEE IT'S NOW BEEN ABLE TO
JOIN US HERE THEY GIVE AS
YOU'VE HEARD FROM SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SPOKEN TODAY.
SO MANY OF US HAS BEEN. BY
ADDICTION. WHETHER WE STRUGGLED
SELVES WEATHER WE'VE HAD A
LOVED ONE OR A FAMILY MEMBER
WHO HAS STRUGGLED THIS IS
SOMETHING. THAT TOUCHES ALL OF
OUR LIVES AND- WINDY MCINTYRE
IS WHEN I I'VE GOTTEN TO KNOW
THE COURSE OF THE PAST YEARS
WE'VE- BEEN DEVELOPING
LEGISLATION WHEN HE IS. AT THE
COUNTER AS- FIVE JERRY IT'S LAW
AND A PATIENT ADVOCATE AND
THAT. SHOWS SHARE HER STORY AND
HER PARENTS WITH THE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT INDUSTRY AND
THEN WE WILL OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. HI WENDY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH I HAD ONE OF THOSE
MORNINGS WHERE YOU FEAR I'M
GONNA BE LATE BECAUSE NONE OF
THE ALARMS GO ON AND THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENED BUT I JUST WANT
TO SAY GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. NAME IS WENDY
MCINTYRE. I FOUND THE CHAIRS
LÀ SHORTLY MY STE JERRY DIED
IN A ROW AGREE HAVE IRONICALLY
CALLED. THE SAFE HOUSE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR. THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME TO SHARE MY
STORY. AND THANK YOU FOR
CONVENING THIS AND FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE WORK YOU'VE DONE ON
THESE ISSUES. WHEN I GOT THE
PHONE CALL TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR THAT NO PARENT WANTS TO
GET I WANTED TO STAND BACK. AND
STAY THERE. BUT INSTEAD I
DECIDED TO BECOME BETTER NOT
BETTER. NOW I DEDICATE THE REST
OF MY LIFE TO SAVING OTHERS. MY
STORY IS NOT UNIQUE I STAND
HERE TODAY THE HUNDREDS OF
VICTIMS WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
LIVES IN ROGUE REHABS. I
INVESTIGATE THESE THAT'S DALY
I'M HORRIFIED AT WHAT
DISCOVERED. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN I GOT A CALL FROM
ABOUT ANOTHER BOY DONOVAN DOYLE.
LIKE MY SON JARED HE DIED IN A
ROBBERY HAVE. CARRIE ROBERTS
CHAT ERIC JAMES MATH CORY AND I
COULD GO ON AND ON. IN A FEW
MINUTES YOU'RE GONNA BE HEARING
FROM JACK LONDON THAT SHOULD
THE TWIN SISTER OF HARRIS AND
UNFORTUNATELY LOST HIS LIFE
ROGUE REHAB RIGHT HERE IN
ORANGE COUNTY. IN FACT AFTER
HEARING I'M GOING TO ACCOMPANY
HER PARENTS TO SANTA ANA
SUPERIOR COURT JURY TRIAL WILL
BEGIN TO DECIDE THE FATE OF THE
PERSON RESPONSIBLE FOR HIS
DEATH. THE WEEK DOESN'T GO BY
THAT I DON'T GET A CALL FROM
HER BROKEN MOM OR DAD. I KEEP
COMING TO THE STATE THIS LIST
OF DEAD BODIES MONTH AFTER
MONTH AFTER MONTH. AND IT FALLS
ON DEAF EARS. TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE DIED YESTERDAY OF
OVERDOSES IN TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE
TODAY. CALIFORNIA STATE
REGULATORS HAVE INVESTIGATED
MORE THAN A HUNDRED NINETY ONE
DEATHS THE TREATMENTS AND
CENTERS SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN. THIS NUMBER IS MISLEADING
BECAUSE THE DEATHS DO NOT
INCLUDE SOBER LIVING HOMES
BECAUSE OUR LIVING ROOMS DON'T
HAVE TO REPORT THOSE DEATHS.
I'M HERE TO GIVE A VOICE TO THE
VICTIMS SURVIVORS AND FIGHTERS
WE CHALLENGE THIS BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY THAT PLACES
PROFIT OF. THIS SECTION AND THE
FEAR OF BEING JUDGED WILL OFTEN
HAVE FAMILIES WAITING TO THE
LAST MINUTE TO REACH OUT FOR
HELP. THEY OFTEN FEEL TERRIFIED
ALONE AND DESPERATE TO FIND
HELP FOR THE LOVED ONES. SOME
PROVIDERS FIRST IT WILL
STRATEGICALLY. HONEST FEAR TO
GET A YOUNG PERSON AND THEIR SO
CALLED TREATMENT PROGRAM.
WITHOUT ACTUALLY PROVE VITAL
MUCH IN THE WAY OF CARE. FOR
MANY FAMILIES THIS PREDATORY
BEHAVIOR WILL APPEAR AS A GIFT.
A KIND AND COMPASSIONATE
STRANGER WHO CAN ANSWER THEIR
PRAYERS. UNTIL THE DAY THEIR
CHILD HAS RETURNED HOME IN A
BODY BAG. SHARES LÀ IS ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO GET SOBER AND US.
HEALTHY AND SAFE WAY. THERE
MUST BE SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE.
JERRY IS A LOT IT'S ABOUT
TAKING THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE WHEN BAD
THINGS HAPPEN. CALIFORNIA IS
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE NATION AND WE MUST DO
BETTER. FOR PATIENTS AND I'M
GOING TO SAY THAT BECAUSE THE
STATE HAS NOT CONSIDER PEOPLE
AND TREATMENT PATIENTS THEY
THINK THEIR CLIENTS. ON
VACATION. AND THESE DETOX
FACILITIES WHERE MEDICINE IS
BEING PRACTICE THERE. IS
CONSIDERED A NON MEDICAL
FACILITY SOME GRATEFUL THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE SOME NEW
LEADERSHIP AS THAT DEFINITELY
NEEDS CHANGE. AS A SAFER STARS
WE NEED TO STARTED KNOWLEDGE
AND THESE ARE PATIENTS SEEKING
RECOVERY NOT INCIDENT CATION A
DETOX HOUSE WERE LEVEL
MEDICATIONS ARE BEING
ADMINISTERED BY UP AND STAFF.
IS CURRENTLY LIKE I SAY
CONSIDERED A NON MEDICAL
KHILADI. IT'S A HIGH WIRE ACT.
OF ADMINISTER UP TO SIXTEEN
MEDICATIONS TO GROWING
PRAGMATIC TO CAME TO THE
SPECIFIC T. ONLY TO GET ON ONE
DRUG. I'M HERE TODAY IS GEARED
SMALL AND THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
OTHER ACTIVISTS MOTHER FATHER
SEEKING CHANGE. OF CHANGE WON'T
HELP BRING. HER CHILDREN BACK.
IT WILL CREATE A LEGACY FOR
FUTURE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES TO RECEIVE SET FOR
TRADE. COUNTRY IN FACILITIES
LIKE SOBER LIVING HOMES NEED
TOUGHER STANDARDS BETTER SCREEN
AND MORE OVERSIGHT. REGULATORY
GAPS MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO KNOW
THE QUALITY OF SOBRE LOOKING ON
DISABILITIES AND REHABS AND
TYPE OF QUALITY OF SERVICES
THEY PROVIDE AND THE STANDARDS
AND REQUIREMENTS AND WHICH THEY
OPERATE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH CHAIRMAN
PETRIE-NORRIS AND HER
BIPARTISAN SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT WORKING GROUP FUTURE
LEGISLATION TO TACKLE THESE
ISSUES. AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION TO FOLLOW CONCERNS
PUT FORWARD TODAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I'D NOW LIKE TO
INTRODUCE CHAPLAIN. YEAH HI MY
NAME IS JACQUELINE DINNER THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING UP
HERE I REALLY APPRECIATE IT MY-
TWIN BROTHER. HIS NAME IS
HARRISON HE DIED AT A REHAB
CENTER IN ORANGE COUNTY WHEN HE
IS TWENTY YEARS OLD. AND I WAS
DUE TO INSURANCE FRAUD BODY
BROKERING A MISDIAGNOSIS
PURPOSELY TO INCREASE INSURANCE
CLAIMS AND PROCESS LIKE YOU
TOUCHED ON MY PARENTS ARE.
RIGHT NOW IN THE TRIAL AGAINST
THE NURSE PRACTITIONER WHO
INCORRECTLY IN PURPOSELY
DIAGNOSE HARRISON AS I HEAR AN
ADDICT. AND THEY GAVE HIM A
DIFFERENT TYPES OF DRUGS. WITH
FETAL WARNINGS THAT SHE WAS NOT
ADMINISTERED TO GIVE AND THEN
LEFT HIM ALONE WITH NO
SUPERVISION TO DIE. AND SO I
JUST WANTED TO COME UP HERE TO.
YOU KNOW. ASK IF WE CAN LIKE WE
TOUCHED ON AND BARRY BROKERING
BUT ALSO INCREASE STAFFING AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. TO ALLOW FOR PROPER
OVERSIGHT THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS ENTIRE TIME
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THERE'S ONLY
SIXTEEN STAFF MEMBERS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE OVERSEEING FOUR
THOUSAND. AND MORE A REHAB
FACILITY IS AN ORANGE COUNTY.
IN CALIFORNIA- AND SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVEN'T TOUCHED ON IT
IS INCREASING AMERICA MEDICAL
MALPRACTICE CAP- TO HOLD
MEDICAL PRACTITIONERS MORE
ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE RIGHT NOW.
EVEN IF THERE IS THE DEATH OF
ALL THEY CAN ONLY BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE UP TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. THANK
YOU. AND WHEN I THINK BOTH OF
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY AND.
AND FOR BEING WILLING TO SHARE
YOUR STORY AND WHEN THE ISSUE.
IS YOU HAVE BEEN DOING FOR SO
MANY YEARS TO TURN YOUR GRIEF
INTO ACTION IN AN INTERACTION
FOR SAVING. SAVING OTHER
CHILDREN ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU AND I THINK AS I SAID
TO YOU BEFORE IT IS LONG PAST
TIME THAT WE ESTABLISH. GAME
PROTECTIONS FOR PATIENTS THAT
ARE IN SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT WE HAVE FOR PATIENTS
RECEIVING ANY OTHER KIND OF
MEDICAL TREATMENT NOTS THAT IS
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY. THANK YOU
AND AT WITH THAT. WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND OPEN UP TO YOU TO
PUBLIC COMMENT I IF YOU CAN
JUST FROM A LINE AT THAT PODIUM
AND JUST IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME WE WOULD LIKE TO ASK IF
EVERYONE CAN CAN LIMIT.
COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
JUST TO HAVE EVERYONE CAN HAVE
A CHANCE TO SPEAK. MY NAME IS
LAURIE DURANT AND ADVOCATES FOR
RESPONSIBLE TREATMENT I WANT TO
THANK THE REPRESENTATIVES THAT
ARE HERE TODAY BECAUSE WE KNOW
HOW HARD YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE AND OUR COMMENTS ARE
REALLY DIRECTED TO THE REST OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT ISN'T HERE
TODAY. AT FIVE AM ON THE
MORNING OF DECEMBER SECOND TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OWNERS OF SAN
JUAN CAPISTRANO HILLSIDE HOME
AWAKEN TO SOMEONE RINGING IT AT
THEIR DOOR BELL AND POUNDING A
ROCK ON THEIR DOOR AND WINDOW
WHICH BROUGHT. ALL CHERUBS.
FROM THE SAFETY OF THEIR
BALCONIES. ENGAGE THE YOUNG MAN
WHO WAS DRENCHED FROM HEAD TO
TOE HE YELLED THAT HE WAS COLD
AND WET FROM SWIMMING IN A
SWAMP. AND HAD BEEN CHASED BY
MEXICANS. HE SAID HIS ANKLE WAS
BROKEN. CODY STEPHENSON SAID HE
WAS FROM FLORENCE SOUTH
CAROLINA HE WAS CITED IN A
SOBER LIVING HOME. THE HOUSE
NEXT DOOR IS A STATE LICENSE
DETOX OCEAN RIDGE TREATMENT AND
RECOVERY. AFTER A SECOND CALL
TO SHARON'S CLAIMING A PROWLER
SHARES ARRIVED AND COULD BE
LEFT IN AN AMBULANCE. THE
NEIGHBORHOOD THE DETOX AND CODY
ARE FORTUNATE THAT HE WAS NOT
SHOT BY SHERIFF'S. BUT WAS HE
FOUND FACEDOWN ROUNDED SOMEONE
SWIMMING POOL. BECAUSE A STATE
DOES NOT REVIEW POLICE AND FIRE
RECORDS THE STATE WOULD NEVER
HAVE KNOWN ABOUT THIS EVENT.
EXCEPT ABRAMS HAD PRIOR
EXPERIENCE FILING COMPLAINTS.
ON TWENTY FOURTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN MARK BALLAS THE SON OF
FORMER CHICAGO PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
PAUL VALLAS HAD OVERDOSED IN
HUNTINGTON BEACH. THE HOUSE.
WHAT THE STATE NOW CALLS
RECOVERY RESIDENTS OPERATED BY
STATE CERTIFIED NEW EXISTENCE
RECOVERY. THE FAMILY ANNOUNCED
HIS DEATH. DH CS CLAIMED IT
COULD NOT INVESTIGATE. TWO
WEEKS LATER THE CO OPERATOR
TEMPLIN OVERDOSED AND DIED.
FOUR MONTHS LATER. ANOTHER BODY
DEPART THE SAME HOUSE ON A
STRETCHER. ONE OF THE
LEGISLATURE RECOVERY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION'S LOBBYISTS SOBER
LIVING AS FAMILY LIKE JUST A
GROUP OF SUPPORT OF ADULTS
READING THE SAME HOUSE THIS IS
PATENTLY FALSE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THESE HOUSES ARE
OPERATED AND SUPERVISED BY FOR
PROFIT BUSINESSES. IT HAS THE
POWER TO REGULATE BUSINESS YEAR
WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO COUNT
THE NUMBER OF BEDS TRACK
RECOVERING ADDICTS COME FROM
AND WHERE THEY GO. ENSURE THE
QUALITY OF SERVICES PROVIDED
REQUIRE FINGER PRINTING AND
DRUG TESTING OF THOSE INVOLVED
INVESTIGATE FOR INSURANCE FRAUD
AND DEMAND HIGHER SUCCESS
RATES. YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
REQUIRE THE BEDS GO FIRST TO
CALIFORNIANS WOULD RECOVERING
ADDICT JUMPED OFF THE TOP OF A
PARKING LOT YOU HAVE THE
ABILITY TO IDENTIFY THE LAST
TREATMENT. PROGRAM ATTENDED AND
SHUT IT DOWN. GATHER THE DATA.
KNOW THE NAMES REGULATE THIS
INDUSTRY. SAVE LIVES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TODAY AN ENEMY THE A
BLACK WELL I AM THE MOTHER OF.
ONE METHOD. MANY MANY YEARS
TRAVELING IN AND OUT OF THE
SOBER LIVING HOMES COSTA MESA
AND IF YOU MISS CENTERS ORANGE
COUNTY PART OF A GATED
COMMUNITY OFFERED BY THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT TIMES AND
THAT IS ON PLACE TO GET SO
BERMAN PARENTS THINK OF MY
CHILD'S IN JAIL WHO GET CLEAN
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO HAPPEN. IN
MORE EXPERIENCES INTO THE
GATHERED OCTOBER RECOVERY. AND
ALL THAT IF WE WILL TALK ABOUT
THE BOTTOM BURKE GREEN WE WERE
PART OF THAT WE ACTUALLY LIVE
THAT LIFE IN PEOPLE WILL LOOK
AT THIS AND SAY. HOW COULD THAT
HAPPEN YOUR FAMILY WE DIDN'T
KNOW WE DIDN'T HAVE RESOURCES
AND WHEN A PLACE IN LAGUNA
BEACH STARTED THE BODY BURGER
MY SON. AND I THOUGHT WAIT A
MINUTE THIS DOESN'T SOUND RIGHT
I'M NOT AN ATTIC SO IN MY HEAD
WHAT THEY WERE OFFERING HIM
SENATE COMPLETELY OUT OF. THE
REALM OF POSSIBILITY AND I GOT
ALONG WITH THE INSURANCE
COMPANY. AND I FOUND OUT THAT
THE THAT THE SOBER LIVING- THE-
RECOVERING RECOVERY CENTER. WAS
NOT RELEASING HIM OFF THEIR
BOOKS THEY HAD THEIR MINDS SENT
HIM SOMEWHERE ELSE. IN MY HOME.
TURNS CAM HE'S NOT ANY STANDING
HERE IN FRONT OF ME WE'RE
TRYING TO GET HIM TO A PLACE IN
RIVERSIDE. BECAUSE MY SON HAD
FINALLY AT IS EIGHT TRY IT
REHAB. AFTER I CAN TELL YOU HOW
MANY JAILS STAYS A PRISON TERM
HAD. FINALLY AT THE LOSS OF HIS
SECOND COUSIN COMMITTING. THE
SITE IT WAS HIS ROCK BOTTOM AND
HE WANTED HELP. AND WE FOUND A
PLACE ON RIVERSIDE. AND I
REMEMBER THEN WE WHEN YOU
DROPPED HIM OFF AT NIGHT. INTO
A ROOM DON'T EVEN BOTHER
GETTING US BACK TO ORANGE
COUNTY BECAUSE OUR HOME IS NOT
AN OPTION. THE PEOPLE THERE ST.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE MONEY WITH
US ABOUT FINDING YOUR SON'S
SOBRIETY AND WE WILL DO
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO DO THAT
AND THEY DID AND HE HAS OVER
THREE YEARS SOBRIETY WITH HIM.
WHEN YOU GOT WAY TO LEAVE THE-
THE RECOVERY. THEY THAT THEY
FOUND A PLACE CALLED THE HOUSE
THE COURAGE WE HAVEN'T HEARD OF
A PEN OR I RIVERSIDE COUNTY
LOOK AT THE HOUSE THE COURAGE
THEY HAVE SEVERAL HOMES ARE
AMAZING. IN PART OF IT IS WE
HAVE TO BE WILLING TO PAY HIS
MONTHLY RENT FOR THREE MONTHS
HE COULD DO NOTHING BUT A TEN
IOP. BECAUSE IF YOU WERE INSANE
TREATMENT YOU COULD NOT STAY IN
THEIR HOME HE THE LIVING THERE
FOR TWO YEARS WHEN HE ARRIVED.
MY HUSBAND AND MY TOPIC IT DOES
GET THIRTY DAYS HERE. TWO YEARS
A COMPLETELY CHANGED HIS LIFE
BEING IN THE RIGHT PLACE WITH
THE RIGHT HELP. WHAT WE WENT
THROUGH AN ORANGE COUNTY WAS A
NINETEEN YEAR. PLACE IS I HATE
TO SAY THE WORDS SHOULD SHOW
BUT IT IS. AND I'M GLAD TO SEE
THIS FINALLY SOMETHING BEING
DONE AND IT MAKES ME SAD THAT.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THAT SOME OF
YOUR BILL THAT YOU PUT
TOGETHER. WE'RE NOT PAT PASSED
ON BOARD BECAUSE THEY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. AND JARED'S MOM. WE
LIVED EVERY DAY WAITING FOR
THAT PHONE CALL AND WE THANK
GOD EVERYDAY THAT IT HAS NOT
COME IN OUR SON. IS DOING
REALLY WELL RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
HE LIVES IN RIVERSIDE HE
REFUSES TO COME BACK TO ORANGE
COUNTY BECAUSE HE SAID. THERE'S
NOTHING FOR ME HERE. AND HE
KNEW HE HAD TO GET AWAY AND I
THINK PARENTS FROM OTHER STATES
THINK- THINK DISCARD THE STATE
THEY'LL BE THEY'LL GET HELP
THERE. THAT ISN'T RIGHT AND AT
ONE POINT HE WAS MANAGING THE
SOBER LIVING TOWARDS AND OF HIS
STAY THERE. AND THEY HAD IN THE
SAID THE WORST THING WAS
CALLING APPARENT. ELEVEN TWELVE
ONE TWO O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING
SAYING YOUR CHILD'S BEING PUT
OUT ON THE STREET. EVERY TIME I
MADE THAT CALL MOM I PICTURED
YOUR FACE WHEN YOU GOT THOSE
CALLS. AND THEY HAVE TO DO IT
FOR THE FOR THE. I INTEGRITY OF
THE HOUSE OF THEIR IN IN TO
HELP EVERYBODY ELSE'S SOBRIETY
SO IT'S HARD IT'S A VERY HARD
THING BUT I JUST CANNOT EXPRESS
MY GRATITUDE. AT HOW HAPPY I AM
THAT THIS IS GOING FORWARD AND
I WOULD LIKE TO OFFER ANY HELP
I CAN GIVE ON YOUR PANEL OR
WITH YOUR GROUP. YOU KNOW IN
THE FUTURE THANK YOU THINK MY-
CHECK YOU. IN YOUR STORY.
MORNING MY NAME'S UNCLE I LOST
MY TWENTY. ABANDONED TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE HE SPENT
THE LAST FIFTY FIFTY FOUR DAYS
OF HIS LIFE IN A TREATMENT
CENTER IN COSTA MESA I HE WAS
WITH THREE PEOPLE OF THE INVEST
OVERDOSED AND LIFE WOULD BE
INSIDE WITH UNLOCKS OWN OUT WE
HAVEN'T TOUCHED ON THIS YET-
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT EVERY
TREATMENT CENTERS SOBER LIVING
HOME. IS EQUIPPED WITH UNLOCK
SOME STAFF HAVE TO BE TRAINED
CLIENTS HAVE TO BE TRAINED AND
WHEN THE CLIENTOF THE POTENTIAL OF SAVING
LIVES HARVARD MEDICAL SCHOOL
DID REPORT SHOWED THAT IT TAKES
ON AVERAGE THREE TO FOUR
TREATMENT EPISODES AND EIGHT
YEARS TO ACHIEVE ONE YEAR OF
SOBRIETY FOR NOPE YOU JUST TO
SORT OF WE NEED TO KEEP KEEP
PEOPLE ALIVE AND WHILE BETWEEN
THESE EPISODES. WE HAVE A
HANDFUL OF SOBER LIVING HOMES
PERPETUAL ACCOMMODATE PEOPLE ON
OPIATE REPLACEMENT THERAPY
DOCTOR HOMES TOUCHED ON IT WE
HAVE A DRUG THE GOLD STANDARD
OF CAPITAL FOR WE HAVE THE
INJECTABLE FORM THAT CANNOT BE
DIVERTED IT LOOKS OF SUB
LOCATE. OUT WE HAVE TO
INCENTIVIZE DOCTORS TO
PRESCRIBE. FOR TO BE WITHIN
PRODUCED A SODA OUT WE HAVE A
RIDICULOUS THING CALLED THE X.
LICENSE EVERY DOCTRINE THIS
COUNTRY HAS TO HAVE A LICENSE
TO DESCRIBE NOT FRIEND INTO ANY
DOCTOR CONTEST. CRIED THE KILL
THE PEOPLE OFTEN IS THE SAFEST
OPIOID WE HAVE- IT'S A PARTIAL
AGONIST. AND IT IS THE GOLD
STANDARD OF CARE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. HI MY
NAME'S MERRY ORDER AND MY
SOBRIETY DATE IS AUGUST FIRST
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE I GOT
SOBER IN HAWAII IN THAT YEAR
AND THEY HAD FULL SERVICES YOU
COULD GO TO COUNSELING YOU
COULD HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO
LIVE. YOU COULD SEE
PSYCHIATRISTS. YOU COULD HAVE
MEDICAL HELP EVERYBODY IN
HAWAII EITHER HAD HEALTH
INSURANCE OR THEY WERE COVERED
BY THE STATE SO I WANT YOU TO
THINK. FOR YOU START CLOSING.
PLACES THEN THERE'S GOING TO BE
IN SERVICES NEEDED TO BE IN
PLACE FOR PEOPLE WITH ADDICTION
PROBLEMS. SAM THAT'S MY SCHOOL.
THANK YOU. HI AM SRI DAILY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM
DICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS AND I REPRESENT
THE COUNSELORS THE TREATMENT
PROGRAMS IN THE SEVERAL LIVINGS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OR AS I
LIKE TO CALL THEM GOOD APPLES
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT-
ASSEMBLY WOMAN IS BEING VERY
HUMBLE ABOUT HER NEW ROLE AT
THE STATE CAPITOL SHE CAME IN
AS A FRESHMAN FEET BARELY WET
SAYS STARTED THE FIRST AS HE
CARCASS OUR STATE HAS EVER HAD.
SHE CALLED EVERY TREATMENT
PROVIDER ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTS TREATMENT AND
CLIENTS. INTO HER SHE AT OFFICE
REFRESHMENT BUT. STILL SMALL.
SOUNDS ALL DOWN IN OUR OFFICE
ON THE COUCH AND SAID HOW DO I
FIX THIS SHE DIDN'T SAYS
ROBINSON SAY YOU'RE AWFUL
PEOPLE YOU'RE KILLING PEOPLE
SHE SAID YOU KNOW THE BUSINESS
YOU TELL ME HOW TO MAKE THESE
THINGS STOP. AND THEN SHE WON'T
ONE STEP FURTHER SHE CO
AUTHORED THE BILL TO MAKE
OUTPATIENT SERVICES MANDATORY
LICENSURE. AND THEN WHEN THAT
BILL GOT IN TROUBLE WITH SOME
POLITICAL SHENANIGANS SHE
ACTUALLY TOOK OVER THAT BILL
PUT IN ONE OF HER OWN BILLS SAT
AT THE STATE CAPITOL ON THE
LAST NIGHT. AND GOT THAT BILL
TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK HE'S
RETURNED IT WAS SOME
SUGGESTIONS OR WE'RE GOING TO
GET IT THROUGH THE YEAR BUT WE
WOULD HAVE DONE IT WITHOUT HER.
I'M TELLING YOU SHE JUMPED IN
AND SAID. AND MYSELF. IN
ADDITION TO THAT SHE ALSO GOT
PASSED AND SIGNED. EIGHTY NINE
NINETEEN WHICH DOES EXACTLY
WHAT YOUR LOCAL. OF LOOK
LEGISLATORS ARE ASKING FOR.
BRING HERE WITH THE TICKET HAVE
A TICKET BACK. FOR A YEAR IF
YOU'RE GOING TO OFFER HOUSING
WHICH IS NOT ILLEGITIMATE WE
HAVE A LOT OF LEGITIMATE
PROVIDERS AS A CONTINUUM OF
CARE YOU CAN'T KEEP PEOPLE IN
TREATMENT FOREVER THEY GET ON
WITH THIRTY DAYS THEY'RE LIVING
BERMAN ISN'T CONDUCIVE TO
RECOVERY. THEY GET A SOBER
LIVING THAT MIGHT BE OWNED BY
THE SAME TREATMENT PROGRAM.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH THAT BE
TRANSPARENT EXPLAINED TO THE TO
THE CLIENTS OR PATIENTS. WHAT
THEY'RE GETTING SO THAT BILL
ALSO DOES THAT IT'S FABULOUS.
WE'VE GOT TONS OF THINGS TO
WORK ON. THE LAST THING I WANNA
LOVE YOU LEAVE YOU WITH IS
CURBING YOU KNOW WHO DOES MOST
OF THE CURBING YOUR INSURANCE
COMPANIES I REPRESENT THE
LEGITIMATE PROVIDERS WHEN A
DOCTOR- WORDS OUR DOCTOR HERE.
WITH THEIR- SAYS YOU NEED YOUR
MEDICAL NECESSITY IS THIRTY
DAYS THAT'S NOT A LOT OF TIME
I'M YOUR HEAD IS NOT EVEN IF
YOU'VE BEEN USING FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S
NEGLECTED ITS TREATMENT SYSTEM.
AND YOU'RE GOING TO TREATMENT
FOR THE FIRST TIME. YOU'RE
BARELY THINKING WALKING. AND
BEING ABLE TO START YOUR
RECOVERY AT THIRTY DAYS SO WHEN
AN INCH WHEN IT WHEN A
PHYSICIAN SAYS YOU GET THIRTY
DAYS. AND SIX DAYS LATER. AND
WITH A CALL FROM THAT ENSURE
SAYING YOU'LL NO LONGER MEET
MEDICAL NECESSITY. WHAT HAPPENS
TO THAT PERSON THESE ARE EVIL
TREATMENT PROVIDERS THROWING
PEOPLE ON THE STREETS ALTHOUGH.
THERE ARE THE BAD APPLES AND
WE'RE WORKING HARD TO GET RID
OF THEM. BUT IT'S ALSO THE GOOD
APPLES IN IS BECAUSE INSURANCE
DOESN'T WANT TO PAY FOR THIS
BECAUSE IT BECAME A MANDATORY
BENEFIT UNDER THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT AND THEY WENT WOW
THAT'S EXPENSIVE. HERE'S HOW WE
GET RID OF IT WE DENY PEOPLE.
WE MAKE THEM STEP DOWN TO
TREATMENT THAT IS NOT
SUFFICIENT FOR THEIR NEEDS. AND
WE OBJECT THEM FOR MEDICAL
NECESSITY SO THAT'S- A HUGE UP
WE'VE GOT TO. GO AFTER NEW
JERSEY NEW YORK PENNSYLVANIA IF
THE DOCTOR SEARCH THIRTY DAYS
YOU GET THIRTY DAYS. INSURE
DOESN'T. COME BACK AND SAY.
YOU'RE DONE OUT ON THE STREETS.
SO I AM. I'VE BEEN LOBBYING FOR
THIS INDUSTRY FOR HONEST
HONORABLE THIRTY YEARS AND THIS
IS JUST A NEW DAY SACRAMENTO
AND PRIMARILY BECAUSE- OF THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN SO THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS MONICA RICHARDSON I'M A
DOCUMENTARY FILMMAKER AND
ACTIVIST AND THE VICTIM'S
ADVOCATE. I HAVE MANY MOTHERS
HAVE CONTACTED ME WITH THE
CHILDREN. OF THE RE HAVE
INDUSTRY NEEDS TO BE REGULATED
AND I WANT TO JUST SAY THIS.
WHY IS AN UNREGULATED ANONYMOUS
SOCIETY FROM THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES THE COMMON FOUNDATION
IN OUR TREATMENT INDUSTRY
TODAY. IF MY BREAST CANCER THAT
I HAD WAS TREATED LIKE IT WAS
IN NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE I COULD
BE DEAD. WE HAVE LOTS OF NEW
INNOVATIONS TO SCIENCE I WANT
TO MAKE A PLUG FOR SMART
RECOVERY SELF MANAGEMENT AND
RECOVERY TRAINING IS AROUND
TWENTY FIVE YEARS IT OFFERS
FACE TO FACE MEETINGS. THEY
HAVE TRAINED LEADERS. NOBODY
LABELS THEMSELVES AN ALCOHOLIC
OR AN ADDICT ANYMORE IT'S KIND
OF PRETTY OLD. WHY IS IT EASIER
OR LET'S SAY IT'S HARDER TO
OPEN A NAIL SALON. THAT A RIO
OKAY IF YOU'RE OF THAT YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A BACKGROUND CHECK BUT
IF I'M GOING TO HELP. SOMEBODY
WHO HAS ALCOHOL OR PROBLEMATIC
DRUG USE THAT I CAN BE ANYBODY
I CAN BE AN ECSTATIC DURING
EXTREME CURRENT ALMOND ON I
KNOW NO ACTUALLY THAT'S NOT
REALLY THE CASE. I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT CARLOS RODON WHO WAS
MURDERED BY A COURT ORDERED
VIOLENT OFFENDER IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. IN A REVIEW OF
IN SAP. BECAUSE IT A THOUSAND
DOLLARS A DAY FOR COLLARD TO
SLEEP ON THE FLOOR WITH FOUR
OTHER WITH THE ROOM THIS IS A
HOUSE THAT WAS FOURTEEN HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET THERE WERE TWENTY
PEOPLE IN THAT ROOM WHY IS BLUE
CROSS PAYING A THOUSAND DOLLARS
A DAY FOR CARLY BE TO BE DRIVEN
TO THAN A SOBER LIVING. IN
SANTA CLARITA WHERE IT THERE IS
DIVERSION PROGRAMS AND ALL THE
MEN WORST THEY'RE BEING DRIVEN
TO IN THAT A MEETING WERE
DIVERTED FROM GOING TO JAIL. AT
HIS A VIOLENT OFFENDER WHO WAS
COURT ORDERED J. FIFTY FIVE
TIMES OVER TWENTY YEARS SHE WAS
DEAD WITHIN FOUR MONTHS. YOU
KNOW IT DIDN'T HELP HIM. THERE
ARE WAYS PEOPLE TALKED ABOUT
THE OTHER WAY IS THE SCIENCE
MEDICATION CO OCCURRING TRAUMA
IT'S A LOT OF OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE HAPPENING TODAY AND I ALSO
WANT TO JUST SAY SOMETHING THAT
I NOTICE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH THE SPENDING A LOT OF
MONEY ON VAPING ADDS. HOW MANY
PEOPLE DIED FROM VAPING.
HARRISON TO WE'RE NOT EVEN THE
NUMBERS THAT WHEN DO YOU STE
YOU KNOW GIVES NUMBERS FOR ARE
NOT EVEN FOR ALCOHOL RELATED
DEATHS WERE DEALING WITH OPIOID
SHE WAS WHICH IS DOUBLE THAT
NUMBER BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE STILL
DYING. FROM WITHDRAWALS LIKE
THERE IS A RE BUT I HOPE IT'S
CLOSE NOW SPANISH SPEAKING WHEN
IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES AT A
DETECTIVE TOLD ME ABOUT
DOWNTOWN WHERE THEY WERE TIENE
PEOPLE UP IN AMERICA IN LOS
ANGELES IN A CHAIR SO THEY
COULD GO WITH THROUGH
WITHDRAWALS FROM ALCOHOL
WITHOUT ANY MEDICATION. WHICH
IS REALLY DANGEROUS IT'S. IT'S
REALLY DANGEROUS. HEART ATTACK
SEIZURE. MY RESEARCH THAT IS A
BEAUTIFUL BUILDING THAT LOOKS
LIKE WHERE I WENT. AT CEDARS
FOR MY BREAST CANCER. IT'S A
REAL CLINIC IN A REAL
COMMERCIAL DISTRICT WHY ARE YOU
PEOPLE SO OPPOSED THAT YOU
COULD WE COULD GET INTO THE
REAL INTO THE CENTURY. AND PUT.
EIGHT HOME. A RESIDENTIAL HOME
AND HOW THE REAL CLINICS THAT'S
WHAT THEY DID IN FLORIDA YOU
CAN GO TO FLORIDA AND ACTUALLY
GO TO A REAL DETOX THREE TO
FIVE THERE'S GONNA BE DOCTORS
THE NURSES THERE ALL DAY LONG.
THANK YOU. YOU. THE NOON THANK
YOU I'M BARBARA THEY'LL GLAZE
AND I SERVE ON THE CITY COUNCIL
AND THINGS IN BEACH- I'M SO
GRATEFUL THAT YOU PUT THIS ON
TODAY IT'S TIMELY AS MATTER OF
FACT IT'S REALLY OVERDUE. BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ONE OF
THE THREADS THAT REALLY CAME
THROUGH TO ME. PLEASE FOLLOW.
THE EXAMPLES THAT YOU HAVE OUT
THERE I DON'T CARE IF YOU HAVE
THE FULL RIGHT TO FLORIDA. ON
THE CONSULTATION A CALIFORNIA
CITIES HAD DAVID HAMBURG OUT
HERE TWO SUMMERS AGO. AND IT
WAS WHEN I WAS THE MAYOR
PENNINGTON BEACH AND THE PART
I'M SAYING THAT IS BECAUSE- HE
GAVE US. HE GAVE US STEPS ON
WHAT TO DO BECAUSE OF FLORIDA
WAS AHEAD OF WITH ALL THIS
CRAZINESS. AND THE. LEFT
FLORIDA AND CAME HERE THE- LAST
WEEK OR SO. AND THE PEOPLE ONE
OF THE PEOPLE I KNOW IN THIS
ROOM NANCY CLARK OF NO NANCY
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS NEVER BY
EVER HEARD HER SAY. OH MY GOD
I'VE GOT PEOPLE RUNNING AROUND
LIKE MANIACS PULLING THEIR HAIR
OUT. THEY NEED SHE CARES. SURE
THE PLACE WHERE PEOPLE OF.
BILLS I'VE MET SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THAT. HAS I HAVE STAYED
THERE. THANKS NANCY FOR SAVING
THEIR LIVES. SO I THINK YOU
NEED TO FOLLOW THE- JUST FOLLOW
UP ON THE PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING
IT RIGHT IF YOU HAVE TO GO TO
MINNESOTA. THEN DO THAT- THE
ORANGE COUNTY THE AGENCY IS
WORKING ON REMOVING THE STATE.
YOU KNOW I WILL BE VAN ON
SATURDAY I MEAN. IF THIS HAD A
COMPOUND FRACTURE IN THEIR LEG
IT WOULDN'T BE A BIG DEAL BUT
IF YOU TELL THEM THEY'RE
SCHIZOPHRENIC. THEY CAN'T GET
SERVICES THIS IS RIDICULOUS SO-
I ALSO WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY
WE HAVE A LOT I KNOW GOING ON
AND I KNOW YOU'RE DOING YOUR
BEST TO. TRY AND GET THESE
THROUGH BUT- ORANGE COUNTY NOW
LEADS THE EIGHT. DOES END
TEENAGE SUICIDE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING AND I APPLAUD YOU AND
MISS BATES IN THIS QUICK SILVA
I KNOW YOU'VE GONE UP THERE AND
I KNOW YOU'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
BILLS AND THEY'VE BEEN TURNED
OUT WHY ARE THEY BEING TURNED
DOWN IS IT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION OR THE
PEOPLE STILL IN THE DARK AGES
ABOUT HOW HOW THINGS NEED TO BE
THIS INDUSTRY NEEDS TO BE
REGULATED IT NEEDS TO BE
CERTIFIED IT NEEDS TO BE
LICENSE. AND AT THE END OF THE
DAY. LET'S GET RID OF NOT RATED
BUT LET'S- BUT THE INSURANCE
THEY'RE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF ONE
REAL PEOPLE. AND THAT'S JUST
NOT THE WAY WE WANT QUALITY OF
LIFE IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD SO. I
THANK YOU AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND PLEASE
REACH OUT TO US. IF WE CAN HELP
YOU WE GOT TO GO TO SACRAMENTO
I WENT WITH SHARON QUIRK SILVA
WHEN SHE HAD. A BEES FIVE
SEVENTY NINE I CAN'T REMEMBER
THE NUMBERS BUT- YOU KNOW I'M
SAYING WE NEED WE JUST NEED
MORE REGULATION OVERSIGHT.
COUNTY THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LAUREN
BERRIDGE AND I'M WITH
CONGRESSMAN HARDLY RIDGES
DISTRICT OFFICE AND THEY JUST
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS HEARING AND AGREE THAT
WE NEED BETTER COORDINATION AND
PARTNERSHIP AMONG ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT CITY STATE FEDERAL-
AND- FOR EXAMPLE SAM'S A WHICH
IS THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION. JUST UNVEILED
ITS BEST PRACTICES AND
SUGGESTED GUIDELINES FOR THE
OPERATION OF SOBER LIVING HOMES
AS DIRECTED BY CONGRESS AND THE
SUPPORT ACT AND ALONG WITH A
BIPARTISAN COALITION OF MEMBER
CONGRESSMAN RITA ENGAGED SANSA
DURING THE DEVELOPMENT OF THESE
GUIDELINES. AM AS WE WORK TO
REVIEW THESE GUIDELINES AGAIN
JUST ENCOURAGING THE REACHING
OUT AND CONNECTING- AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE ALL COURT
NEEDED AS WELL AS PART
BIPARTISAN BILL HR THIRTY.
EIGHTY NINE. SENATE BUT IF
ENACTED THE BILL WOULD HELP THE
OFFICE OF NATIONAL DRUG CONTROL
POLICY LEAD THE FIGHT AGAINST
ADDICTION CRISIS- SO AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND LET'S ALL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER. THANK YOU. Q. AND
ABSOLUTE PLEASE. CONGRESSMAN
READ AS I HAVE WORK ON DECEMBER
THE GUIDELINES AND HR THIRTY
NINE. THANK YOU FOR COMING
ASSEMBLY WOMAN. CONNIE
PETRIE-NORRIS IT'S KIND OF A
MAYBE PROVIDENTIAL THAT YOU'VE
COME TO COSTA MESA. THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU MAYOR FOLEY THANK
YOU WENDY AND THINK YOU'RE ALSO
ARE WONDERFUL NANCY CLARK WHO.
YEARS AGO LIVE VERY CLOSE TO
NANCY CLARK'S. SOBER LIVING
HOMES AND DIDN'T EVEN KNOW IT
BECAUSE THEY WERE INVISIBLE AND
SO- I GUESS SOME OF US IN THIS
ROOM FROM COSTA MESA CAN SAY WE
SURVIVED FIFTEEN YEARS OF THE
INVASION- BY SOBER LIVING HOMES
INTO. COSTA MESA TO WRECK HAVOC
BUT I HAVE A COUPLE OF IDEAS
THAT YOU MIGHT CONSIDER SOME OF
THESE THINGS WERE TOUCHED ON
ACTUALLY- MY THIRTY NINE YEAR
OLD SON IS SIX MONTHS OVER.
FROM A HEROIN ADDICTION. AND
THANKFULLY HE- I BELIEVE GOD
LET HIM INTO A GOOD TREATMENT
CENTER THAT IS FROM TUSTIN BUT
IN FIND. HELP BECAUSE I HAVE
LEVERAGE AND I SAID BASICALLY-
IF I IF I MAKE YOUR CAR PAYMENT
WOULD YOU GO WERE YOU GOING TO
DO PARKS THE RECOVERY AND- THAT
WAS WHY HE COOPERATED BUT HE
WAS OUT AT THE BOTTOM. HE HAD
REACHED AT THE BOTTOM AND SO
HAD AYE. AND SO- BUT HERE'S THE
CHALLENGE IS IF ANYBODY WANTS
TO GOING TO DETOX TODAY. THERE
ARE NOT DIG PARTS PLACES FOR
PEOPLE WHO POOR WITHOUT
INSURANCE. THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
IN IN A LOT OF THE HOMELESS
PEOPLE WHO MAY BE DECIDE LIKE
SOMEBODY'S LIVING DOWN OF THE
JUNGLE AT THE END OF NINETEEN
STREET YEAH I'M READY BUT I
NEED TO SAFELY BT DETOX. THERE
AREN'T ENOUGH PLACES THANKFULLY
MY SON HAD JUST GONE ON MEDI
CAL AND THIS PLACE WHERE HE
WENT ALLOWED HIM TO WHERE HE
DETOX AND THEN HE WENT INTO.
LIKE A THREE OR FOUR MONTHS
PROGRAM AND EVERY DAY- I'M
THANKFUL AND I KNOW HE IS TO
AND HE'S YOU KNOW WORKING HAS
RECOVERY BUT THAT DETOX.
ELEMENT IS MISSING- THE OTHER
THING IS I DISCOVERED. ALL
THESE OTHER STATE PEOPLE THE
COMMON THEY GET ON CALIFORNIA
MEDI CAL AND WE'RE PAYING FOR
THEM TO GET RECOVERY IN COSTA
MESA IN CALIFORNIA THERE SHOULD
BE SOME KIND OF RECIPROCATION
WHERE WE BILL THAT STATE THAT
THEY COME FROM. IN ORDER TO
ROUTE TO SAY ALL RIGHT YOU GET
TWO WEEKS OR SOMETHING WE'RE
GOING HOME BUT WE ARE FINE WE
ARE. PUTTING THESE PEOPLE IN
REHAB AND WE'RE PAYING FOR IT
WHEN THEY'RE NOT CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS THE OTHER THING IS
KIND OF A FEDERAL ISSUE WITH
AND I'M THAT OUR REPRESENTATIVE
FROM- CONGRESSMAN ROUTE IS
OFFICES HERE. IS HOMES AT SAY
THEIR HOMES THE IDEA WAS THAT
THEY WERE GOING TO BE GOOD
COMMUNITY NEIGHBORHOOD PICK UP
TRASH SAID YOU KNOW THEY DON'T
THEY'RE KIND OF. ISOLATED
BECAUSE OF THE STIGMA. THERE
THAT'S A CASH BUSINESS IS THE
IRIS REGULATING THEM DO THAT DO
THEY- THE MONEY'S JUST LIKE
UNDER THE TABLE BUT THEY'RE
COLLECTING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ARE MANY HER CURVES SO MANY
THEY START ALL OVER- LAST THING
I WANT TO SAY BECAUSE THE
RESTART ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND OVERSIGHT I WORK AT COLLEGE
HOSPITAL. AND I WORK IN THE
ADOLESCENT UNIT AND THOSE ARE
THE KIDS THAT- WANNA TAKE THEIR
LIVES MANY OF THEM ARE ON
DRUGS. SO WE HAVE TO LOOK THIS
UP THIS IS A MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE- WITH DUAL DIAGNOSIS WITH
SUICIDE IDEATION BUT ALSO WE
HAVE TO AS A- WE HAVE TO AS A
COUNTRY REALIZE THAT OUR KIDS
NEED TO BE YOU KNOW AN
ARTICULATED DID NOT TO TAKE
DRUGS IN THE FIRST PLACE. AND
SO THAT'S PART OF THE ISSUE
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T LOOK AT THE
KIDS LIKE THEY SAID THE OTHER
DAY UPSTREAM. THEN THEY'RE
GOING TO BE YOU KNOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BE REALLY ADDICTS BY
THE TIME YOU KNOW IF WE DON'T
DEAL WITH THE CAUSE AND FIND
OUT WHO. SELLS ALL THE DRIVE.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S GENE CAMPBELL- A
RESIDENT HERE IN COSTA MESA I'M
ALSO A LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKER. AND NEXT MONTH ALL OF
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF SOBRIETY
SO I COME AT THIS FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE- THE EQUATION-
COUPLE OF SUGGESTIONS I WOULD
MAKE BASED ON OVER TWENTY YEARS
OF WORK IN THE RECOVERY
INDUSTRY AND I WANT TO BE
REALLY CLEAR I'M NOT AFFILIATED
WITH. ANY TREATMENT CENTER I'M
INDEPENDENT PRACTITIONER- I AM
WHOLEHEARTEDLY IN FAVOR OF
REGULATING SOBER LIVINGS
ESPECIALLY. AN OUTPATIENT
PROGRAMS AS A LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER I'M REQUIRED TO
DO A LIVE SCAM. WHICH MEANS ON
FINGERPRINTED. THAT'S TRUE FOR
ANY LICENSE CLINICIAN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. IF IT WERE UP TO
ME THAT WOULD BE TRUE FOR
ANYONE WORKING AT ANY LEVEL OF
CARE IN ANY KIND OF ADDICTION
RECOVERY TREATMENT. OR MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT. AND JUST TO
PUT ON YOUR RADAR MENTAL HEALTH
IS THE NEWER ACTION BECAUSE
INSURANCE WILL REIMBURSE IT. IS
THAT THEY USE TO REIMBURSE
ADDICTION SO. PLEASE KEEP THAT
IN MIND MOVING FORWARD THAT
THOSE BAD. ACTORS THE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE. START MOVING OVER AND
HAVE ALREADY STARTED MOVING
OVER INTO. HEALTH ISSUE. A IN
TREATMENTS- AND THOSE FOLKS ARE
INCREDIBLY VULNERABLE AS WELL-
A LOT OF TIME. PLACES GET
LICENSED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
TO ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE JOINT
COMMISSION. THE MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT CHARTS BEING LOCKED
BEHIND A CERTAIN NUMBER OF.
DRAWERS THAN THEY ARE ACTUALLY
ABOUT DIRECT PATIENT CARE. AND
SO THOSE STANDARDS NEED TO BE
REEVALUATED I WOULD ALSO
SUGGEST TO SOMEBODY WHO'S
WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
FAMILIES. I CAN COUNT ON ONE
HAND THE NUMBER OF TREATMENT
CENTERS IN ORANGE COUNTY THAT
HAVE A GOOD FAMILY PROGRAM. AND
IT'S AN UNDERSERVED POPULATION
THE FAMILIES NEED TO BE
EDUCATED THEY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THIS IS. EMIGRATE
BLESSED. ARE SUFFERING AS MUCH
AS THE ADDICTS AND ALCOHOLICS
OR- SO I WOULD REQUIRE THAT
THERE BE ADEQUATE FAMILY
SERVICE. INVOLVED IN ANY
TREATMENT CENTER. THE OTHER
THING IS WITH DOING ALL DUE
RESPECT TO DOCTOR IS. OUT
ACTORS THE LICENSE OF PATIENTS.
WHO ARE OVER PRESCRIBED. IT'S.
ONE OF THEM IT. RIGHT OR
BENZODIAZEPINES LIKE EXAM X.
LIKE OUT OF THEM LIKE VALIUM
THAT IS A HUGE SILENT EPIDEMIC
THAT'S GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW AND IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THOSE NUMBERS
ARE GOING UP. THE LAST THING I
WANT TO JUST MENTION IS UP I
ALSO PUT ON YOUR RADAR THAT'S
KIND OF SEPARATE BUT-
EQUIVALENT TO ME. ONE IS NOW
LEGAL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO KNOW WHO'S
PULLING PEOPLE OVER FOR DO YOU
WISE AND HOW THEY'RE BEING
TESTED. BECAUSE THERE'S NO.
STING GOING ON IN THAT RESPECT
AND WE HAVE PEOPLE ON THE ROADS
EVERY DAY UNDER THE INFLUENCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. I AM I THINK. THIS ISN'T
SURE. ORANGE COUNTY IN TERMS OF
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT ABOUT
TESTING FOR AN FOR MARIJUANA
ORANGE COUNTY'S ACTUALLY
LEADING THE STATE IN TERMS OF
DOING THAT TESTING DOING THAT
ANALYSIS AND TRYING TO
ESTABLISH. THRESHOLDS THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE IS ACTUALLY
DOING DOING SOME REALLY GOOD
WORK THERE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS PERRY FISHER I AM ONE
OF THE VERY FRUSTRATED
HOMEOWNERS LIVING ADJACENT TO
FOR SOBER LIVING HOMES I
TOTALLY GET COSTA MESA HAUSER
ORDINANCE THESE FOR SOBER
LIVING HOMES. COUNTY MY
PROPERTY AND IT ARE LOCATED
WITHIN THREE HUNDRED FEET OF MY
HOUSE MAINLY BECAUSE I LIVE IN
A SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOOD.
AS LONG AS THE RECOVERY HOMES
OPERATE AT SIX RESIDENTS THEY
ARE REQUIRED I UNDERSTAND BY
FEDERAL LAW TO BE TREATED JUST
LIKE EVERY OTHER HOMES IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. SO THERE'S REALLY
I MEAN I HEAR A LOT REGULATION
LICENSING OVERSIGHT DO THIS DO
THAT ENFORCEMENT. HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO GET AROUND THE FITS
AND THEIR REQUIREMENT FIFTIES
HOMES HAVE TO BE TREATED JUST
LIKE MY HOME LIKE MY NEIGHBOR A
COUPLE WITH FOUR CHILDREN.
THERE ARE SIX. IT'S THE SAME
THE ONLY. RECOURSE PEOPLE IN MY
SITUATION HAVE. IS THE CITY'S
NUISANCE LAW. AND I'VE BEEN
ASKING THESE QUESTIONS SINCE
COSTA MESA MAYOR FOLEY CAN TELL
YOU SINCE WE STARTED DOWN THE
ROAD WITH OUR OUR ONE ORDINANCE
LIKE BACK IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
I'M STILL LIVING IN THE SAME
CONDITIONS I STILL WALK IN MY
HOUSE. BECAUSE OF THE PEOPLE
AROUND THE POOL NEXT DOOR TO ME
AND MY HOUSE SMELLS LIKE A
CIGARETTE ASH TRAY NOW LOOK BAD
IN THE VP LET'S ADD IN I VERY
SELDOM LET MY THREE YEAR OLD
GRANDSON GO IN THE BACKYARD
BECAUSE OF THE LANGUAGE.
WHERE'S WHO'S LOOKING OUT FOR
ME WHO'S PROTECTING THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE TO TOLERATE THIS
BECAUSE THERE'S REALLY
BASICALLY NOTHING ANYBODY CAN
DO YOU JUST GO RENT A HOUSE.
YOU BRING IN FIVE MORE PEOPLE
THAT ARE SUPPORTING EACH OTHER
IN THEIR SOBRIETY AND THERE'S
THEIR UNTOUCHABLE. BUT THERE
ARE A LOT OF US ESPECIALLY IN
COSTA MESA IN THE SINGLE FAMILY
AREAS. AND WE ARE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED MULTIPLE TIMES A DAY
MULTIPLE CELL. ANYTHING YOU CAN
FIGURE OUT WORK WITH THE FED
SINCE THERE ARE LAWS AND THEIR
REQUIREMENTS HOW EVER ANYTHING
YOU COULD DO TO TAKE THE BURDEN
OFF. I WOULD APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU. ON A BRIEF THE RES
BRIEFLY RESPOND TO THANK YOU I
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT YOUR- YEP I
APPRECIATE. WHAT A FRUSTRATING
SITUATION NOT AS SO HERE'S MY
CENTRAL BELIEF MY CENTRAL
BELIEF IS THAT MOST OF THOSE
AND YOU KNOW MOST OF THE SOBER
LIVING HOMES THAT ARE. NOT JUST
THEY'RE EXPLOITING OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS THEY ARE ALSO
EXPLOITING PATIENTS- NETWORKS
AS THEY WERE LIVING HOMES ARE
NOT BEING RUN BY COULD
OPERATORS YOU'VE HEARD FROM
SEVERAL PEOPLE. HE SAID NANCY
CLARK STABILITY IS RIGHT MY
BACKYARD DIDN'T EVEN NOW. GOOD
OPERATORS GOOD ACTORS PEOPLE
THAT ARE REALLY HELPING PEOPLE
GET BACK ON THE ROAD TO
RECOVERY. ALSO GOOD NEIGHBOR
WHICH IS WHY FOR ME MY FOCUS
HAS BEEN ON A DRESS SEEN THAT
THE THINGS THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
IN STATE LAW BECAUSE YOU'RE
ALSO RIGHT WE- IF WE WANTED TO
BAN ALL ALSO RELIVING HOMES. WE
CAN'T BECAUSE OF THE FEDERAL I
REALIZE THAT YOU MENTIONED MY
BELIEF IS THAT IF WE GET AT THE
ROOT CAUSE IN WE AT. S. T. TO
SET WE GET RID OF THE PROFIT
MOTIVE THAT IS DRIVING SO MANY
OF THESE OPERATORS THE THESE
ISSUES THAT YOU'RE SICK YOUR
COMMUNITY WILL ALSO BE
ADDRESSED SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSED ON. SO THANK YOU VERY
FISHER THAT'S WHO JUST SPOKE
BECAUSE SHE HAS REALLY DONE OUR
HOMEWORK FOR THE COMMUNITY OF
COSTS MISSUS SHE'S BEEN ON THE
COMPUTER DOING RESEARCH AND IS
NOT AFRAID TO SPEAK UP AND I'M
GLAD SHE'S HERE TODAY SO I'D
ALSO AYE EGGS SO APPLY THE
HALLELUJAH HALLELUJAH I CANNOT
BELIEVE YOU OF PUT THIS
TOGETHER I AGREE WITH EVERY
SINGLE WORD THAT HAS COME OUT
OF ALMOST EVERY SPEAKERS MOUNT
I ESPECIALLY GIVE A SHOUT OUT
TO THE FAMILIES OF PEOPLE THAT
DON'T JUST YOU KNOW THAT. STEP
UP AND TRY TO HELP OTHER
FAMILIES I DON'T LIKE TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO TERRY'S COURSE OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER FOR
HER FABULOUS COVERAGE OF THIS
EPIDEMIC IN IN ORANGE HOW IT'S
AFFECTED. US AND EACH GET A
SURPRISE FOR. BECAUSE WE'RE
BRAIN. I'M SORRY I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT- I'D ALSO LIKE
TO SAY YOU KNOW THIS THE LAW OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS MORE
LIBERAL THAN THE FEDERAL LAW
THAT WAS MENTIONED HERE TODAY
WHY DON'T WE JUST IMMEDIATELY
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO MAKERS
STATE LAW LIKE THE FEDERAL LAW
THAT WOULD PUT A CURB ON QUITE
A BIT OF THIS SECOND OF ALL
OUR- THIRD. SO I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY NO ONE'S TALKING
ABOUT THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM
HERE. THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM
IS POLITICS. THERE IS I YES THE
YOUNG LADY WHO CAME AND SPOKE
EVERYBODY'S YOUNGER THAN ME SO
SHE- ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE
RUNNING A HOME AND EVERYTHING
SO I JUST RAN OUT NOW SIR. YOU
HAVE A REAL ESTATE LICENSE NOW
I FEEL THAT HER. HEART IS IN
THE BEST PLACE BUT IT IS
ASTOUNDING TO ME IN ORANGE
COUNTY HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
RUNNING SEVERAL LIVE IT DOES IS
AND THEY'RE ONLY QUALIFICATION
IS. THAT THEY HAVE REAL ESTATE
LICENSES THEY HAVE NO MEDICAL
BACKGROUND NONE WHATSOEVER. I
HOPE EVERYONE'S AWARE THAT IN
BEVERLY HILLS AND OTHER PARTS
OF CALIFORNIA THEY RUN REAL
ESTATE SEMINARS. PUMP TO ORANGE
COUNTY AND OPEN UP A SOBER
LIVING HOME AND THAT- THE
MOTHER LODE IS IN PARTICULAR
COSTA MESA AND THE REAL MOTHER
LOAD YOU KNOW THE GOLD STREAK
IS EASE SITE COSTA MESA.
TEACHING REALISTIC CLASSES LIKE
THIS. I THINK THE LOBBYIST YOU
THE- NO ONE'S REALLY TALKING
ABOUT THE LOBBYIST IN
SACRAMENTO HERE'S TO LOBBIES TO
KEEP THESE PLACES ROCKING AND
ROLLING. THE CHURCH OF
SCIENTOLOGY THE CHURCH OF
SCIENTOLOGY HOW MANY HOUSES TO
THEIR OWN. IN ORANGE COUNTY YOU
MIGHT LOOK INTO THAT WE HAVE
THE SCOTT BOB WHO IS THE FORMER
HEAD OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
REPUBLICAN PARTY LOBBYIST FOR
THE SOBER LIVING COMMUNITY AND
I THINK IT WAS ALLEN AGAIN I
CAN'T REMEMBER WHICH- OF
PHARMACY. THIS IS THE HE IS THE
LOBBYIST FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE SELLING THE OPIOIDS.
DOESN'T BOTHER ANYBODY THEN WE
HAVE- THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON
CITY COUNCILS THAT ACTUALLY OWN
THESE HOUSES PEOPLE THAT ARE
HEADS OF CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THAT OWN THESE HOUSES. WHY
ISN'T ANYBODY LOOKING INTO THIS
WHY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THE
LOBBY IS INVOLVED IN ALL- NOT
TO MENTION THE REAL ESTATE
COMMUNITY. LOBBYIST YOU KNOW
HOW STRONG THEIR LOBBY IS IN
SACRAMENTO DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH
THEY ABSOLUTELY ADORE THIS NOT
ONLY DO THEY- OWN THE HOUSES.
THEY MARKET TO OVERSEAS THEY
MARKET TO CHINA INDIA. ENGLAND
ANYWAY I CALLED UP VILLA REAL
ESTATE TO FIND OUT WHO THE
MARKET TO. AND THEN THEY
EXPLAINED TO ME HOW THIS WORKS.
THE FOREIGNERS BY THE HOMES
IT'S JUST AN INVESTMENT THEY
DON'T EVEN LIVE IN THE UNITED
STATES THEY COULD CARE LESS
ABOUT YOUR COMMUNITY. THEY MAKE
SO MUCH MONEY DOING THIS THEY
HAVE A. A COMPANY A MANAGEMENT
COMPANY PRINCES IN COSTA MESA
IT'S- IT'S HIM CAR AND HE
MANAGES THESE HOUSES. AND THEY
MAKE MONEY OFF OF THIS THEY
MAKE MONEY OFF OF. THE PEOPLE
MOVE OUT WHEN YOU GET ONE OF
THESE HOUSES IN YOUR COMMUNITY
WE LOST THREE REALLY GOOD
NEIGHBORS BECAUSE KEITH
RANDALL. PUT A SERVER LIVING
FACILITY AT THE END OF THE
BLOCK. AND THEY DID THEY HAVE
SMALL CHILDREN THEY DIDN'T WANT
TO DEAL WITH THAT THEY MOVED
THREE LONG TIME REALLY GOOD
NEIGHBORS. I FEEL THAT THERE'S-
THAT THIS. IS THE ANSWER THE
STATE SHOULD REGULATE THE WAY
THE FED LÀ CHANGE THE STATE
LAW SO IT'S LIKE THE FEDS START
FIGHTING THE LOBBYIST WHY DON'T
WE HAVE A LOBBY WANTED TO
RESIDENTS OF ORANGE COUNTY
WHERE IS OUR LOBBY LET'S GET
TOGETHER TO GET UP THERE. THANK
YOU CUTTING PETRIE-NORRIS
BECAUSE WE ARE FULLY RIVER. NO
BECAUSE THEY'RE LISTENING TO
THE CONSTITUENTS THEY'RE NOT TO
IGNORING US THERE'S TROUBLE.
OUT HERE PLEASE US THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS AL
JABBAR THE DEPUTY CHIEF. BY THE
DECK CHAFEE I JUST WANT TO TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND- MAYOR FOLEY
FOR ACTUALLY HOSTING THIS I
THINK SHARON QUIRK SILVA
ASSEMBLY WOMAN MENTIONED IT
UNLESS YOU HAVE A HEARING AND
BRING FOLKS WHO ARE
INTRICATELY. INVOLVED IN THIS
ISSUES WE AS A POLICYMAKERS
DON'T GET TO HEAR THAT- FINER
OR THAT MOST DIFFICULT PARTS OF
THIS ISSUE. SO I THANK YOU FOR
GIVING THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND I THINK EVERYBODY
WHO IS HERE. PLEASE KEEP US IN
MIND OUR OFFICE IN MY TERMS OF-
BEING ABLE TO HELP YOU- WE-
WITH THAT INPUT FOR LEGISLATION
FROM ORANGE COUNTY. OR ANY ANY
OF THE SERVICES THAT ARE COUNTY
WOULD OPERATE THAT MUCH. YEAH.
THANK YOU AGAIN EVERYONE FOR
JOINING US TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC I
DEFINITELY I. TAKE A SINGLE
HOMEWORK. I WILL JUST BEFORE WE
GO ALL YES I THE QUESTION OF
NINE TWENTY WHICH A COUPLE OF
FOLKS HAVE MENTIONED IT WAS A
BILL THAT I AUTHORED. THAT
WOULD HAD ESTABLISHED
REQUIREMENT FOR ALL OUTPATIENT
DRUG REHAB FACILITIES. IN
CALIFORNIA. TO BE LICENSED AND
WE GOT THAT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THAT. BILL WAS
VETOED THAT BILL WAS VETOED BY
GOVERNOR NEW SAM IN HIS VETO
MESSAGE AND SUBSEQUENTLY IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH. HIS STAFF
HE HAS AFFIRMED HIS BELIEF AND
HIS COMMITMENT TO ENSURING THAT
ALL SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT PROGRAMS. AND
PRACTITIONERS ARE LICENSED IN
THE STATE CALIFORNIA HIS
RATIONALE FOR THE VIDEO IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. IT'S WE'RE IN
A BIT OF A CATCH TWENTY TWO
BECAUSE THERE IS NOTHING THERE
BECAUSE THEY'RE SUCH A VACUUM
IN WHAT EXISTS TODAY IN ORDER
FOR US TO ESTABLISH A LICENSURE
OSKI MAN. HIS RECOMMENDATION
REQUEST IS THAT WOULD BE A LOT
MORE DETAIL SAID THAT AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE THIS
IS HAS MUCH MORE DETAIL MUCH
MORE DIRECTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE IN TERMS OF WHAT
THAT LICENSE YOUR WILL CONSIST
OF. AND WHAT THEY NEED TO DO IN
AND TO GET THEM THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO IMPLEMENT THAT
WHAT'S INTERESTING IT WAS A
REALLY GOOD OPPORTUNITY IN
NINE. IS THAT AS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING AND ABOUT MINNESOTA NOW
THERE'S SOME BEST PRACTICES IN
MINNESOTA I HAD A LOT OF WHAT
EXIT IN MINNESOTA IS CODIFIED
IN STATE LAW IT IS NOT LEFT UP
TO INTERPRETATION BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SO. I AM ACTUALLY
CHOOSING TO SEE THIS AS KIND OF
YOU KNOW WELL IT WAS PLENTY TO
GET THAT. DO YOU THINK IT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO WORK
TOGETHER TO WORK WITH THE STATE
AND FLORIDA WITH EXPERTS LIKE
HAZELDEN BETTY FORD AND OTHERS
TO CRAFT A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND IT ALSO IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT HAS A LOT OF
DETAIL IN TERMS OF WHAT IS
CODIFIED. WE CAN AND GET PASSED
IN IMPLEMENTED NEXT SO THAT IS
ACTUALLY GONNA BE PART OF THE
PACKAGE OF LEGISLATION THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON WITH THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT CAN
GROUP. ALSO BE BEST. A NUMBER
OF OTHER BELLS AND PROGRAM SO
AND. THERE IS A TIE AND THE
TYPE OF WORK THAT WE. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
OFFERING PEOPLE WHO ARE
GRAPPLING WITH ADDICTION. THE
BEST PROGRAMS POSSIBLE SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE. I.
ONE THE CLOSING STATEMENT
BECAUSE I BRING PROBLEMS TO THE
TAPE MISSIONS I WANT US. LET
YOU LEAVE THIS THOUGHT. WE SEND
OUR CHILDREN TO COLLEGE FOR
FOUR YEARS TO GET A DEGREE BUT
WE EXPECT THEM TO BEAT THEIR
ADDICTION AND THIRTY SIXTY OR
NINETY DAY SO WE'VE GOT A BIG
PROBLEM PROBLEMS ALL OVER THE
PLACE BUT WE HAVE THIS. IT'S
TIME TO TURN THIS ON ITS HEAD
AND REALLY COME UP WITH SOME
REAL SOLUTIONS TO THIS. AND
THANK YOU THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU